you get mad at me when i break it
and we are live the last word lord
cognito ibontas thai guy travis on that
thursday destiny
campfire flow
back at it boys first let's start with
ebantus how we doing sir doing good just
kind of been
holding down the home front gonna go on
a quick trip to visit my brother here in
a little bit what up stonewolf i know
you listen to this eventually yeah it's
a very short flight so it's a whole
whopping hour uh so i got that just kind
of prepping stuff around the house and
then um other than that just been
waiting for a whole lot of not much this
week and then wrapping up guardian games
we'll talk about how the week has gone
um other than that just kind of
chilling and waiting to um run through
the next season of destiny next week
travis what about you man
i
am
creating a lot of content for ign some
of it i can't talk about yet but my
review of
uh evil dead the game
should be live now or
if it's not live right now it'll be live
very shortly because uh it's all done
and ready to go
um
but yeah i played a lot of that game
this past week or two um
okay which is great can you say your
score here or is it going to be
published what if it's live i see it
okay i see your score okay
wow
yeah wow i gave it an 8 out of 10. it is
a very clunky game that does things that
annoy the crap out of me but uh
you know
when it when it all it's all said and
done it's uh it's quite a good game
super fun i actually was playing it
right before we started up the show so
um i'm quite enjoying it it's a great
game
and then i've got a i'm doing a tips
guide for people who want to start
playing that game i'm making a video for
like here's all my pro tips which like
i'm pretty good at the game i'm not
gonna lie undefeated uh next so humble
so there you go
the humility loses from travis
so uh yeah uh that that should be live
like maybe over the weekend or on monday
um but yeah i'm working on that and then
uh yeah i got some previews coming up um
probably reviewing something else next
week i don't really know yet uh but yeah
that's me man busy making content how
about you cog
busy man busy work's been absolutely
nuts but um shout out to you on the evil
dead thing because we have miles
don't play from windows central on um
how's somebody's hair looked that good
oh yo his hair is crazy like bro i'm
like y'all
professional stylist going on this man
but he also raved about evil dead we
talked about what we were playing he
mentioned that for me had a little good
good break you know first of all solid
sort of said warlock stand up
the rifle class has has done what they
needed to do everyone can bend the knee
now you mean you got your default win on
the final year to get it that's the
seeking mask that you solid victory
silence you brutes
let the intelligence reign this is our
moment the trophy will look glorious in
the tower i want you to walk past it and
look at that bird and all its glory okay
now that i'm done
we've won it before and i've forgot the
things even in the tower so good stuff i
go for it i used to be salty having to
see that damn
lying every time
i'm like and the bird is all small
like no now we get our moment so i'm
happy shout out to team warlocks the
luck did they think but um no i wanted
to um also shout out track to yomi i got
a chance to play that take a little
break absolutely love it travis like i
told you before i loved your review um
combat we in alignment combat little
for some reason i mastered the counter
system which um ended up becoming like a
dance and i was getting into it but the
story surprised me i was very
understands welcome yeah very impressed
atmospheric storytelling and it reminds
me of an old sega game i used to play
that used to scare me back in there
called considering so check it out it's
in game pass rocking that and other than
that check out the fighting duke's been
fun matt he's been hilarious and uh
enough about me he um we got some people
here that's been
patient and also what's going on we have
one people but we'll get them going so
welcome to the last word episode number
198
just a couple away from 200 so it's
close as we approach a new season of
destiny we are rather clueless as to
what the story will be about what the
new activities will be and other than a
date of the new dungeon bungie is
keeping their cards very close to their
chest
to discuss the final bits of speculation
our guest tonight is one well versed in
persistence consistence and precision
we'll start with precision something
important both gaming and real life
sports if this man isn't working on
honing his skills editing another
youtube video you'll find him on the
links or on the ice more often than not
persistence on the other hand we all
know life throws curves balls at you
busy work schedule injuries and just the
unexpected can sometimes come your way
but that hasn't stopped this man from
growing his channel and becoming another
up-and-coming pillar of the destiny
community finally consistence no matter
the reason the only way to succeed is
sticking with it and this man has the
staying power in spades so let's welcome
a true palace of ideas to make you a
better player someone who spends plenty
of time in his fortress of solitude
grueling over the perfect tier list and
unlike a chessboard this rook has no
issues moving on the diagonal that's
right the one the only castle how you
doing sir hey that was
that was solid
yeah that's what it is impressive my
friend
um doing well honestly yeah no seriously
i'm glad you guys had me on um
pleasure to be on it's uh
it's pleasure it's ours sir
first thing i want to actually get this
right and make this shift going forward
tell everybody since we're at the start
of the show where to find you where to
look you up where your contents at and
then we'll get into stuff because i want
people early in the show while they're
still here figure out where to find you
because that's the important part
that's fair um castle content on
everything so
you know twitter youtube twitch anything
it's just castle content and uh you
should be able to find me
if you search that out indeed nice the
logo may be different in different
places but that's okay
that's great you had to do some
no that was actually fun let me see if i
can recreate this it didn't take long so
it's all good
let's get right to it man you know got
some gaming history questions before we
get into the destiny stuff just want to
get the background man like what is one
of those early inspirations for you to
kind of get into the to the gaming
atmosphere yeah yeah no honestly
probably
it was probably goldeneye or maybe even
street fighter um
which street fighter because there's a
big list in there yeah there is there is
so like i think it would have been
street fighter 2 turbo back on super
nintendo so
i'm uh you know
i i i'm what you would consider a boomer
in the in the gaming community right
welcome
oh you're over 21 you're a boomer um
but yeah no so probably that was
probably the first game when i was a kid
i was really young but
that game like consumed me um
yeah right it was just so it's just
always like your super your character
just like waiting in that idle animation
in that little item position no no
absolutely you kept transitioning on i
saw some golden eye in there and yeah
yeah so probably i would say after that
golden eye um that was probably when
like more of the memorable stuff started
to happen i i
my brother is like four or five-ish
years older than me and he used to
always bring his buddies over after
school like every day so every pretty
much
for like three years straight
every single day after school i don't
know why they wouldn't go to their
houses but they would just come to our
house and we would just split screen
golden eye
you know and then it was halo you know
combat evolved the first one and then it
was it was just like years of constantly
battling
split screen before we had you know like
xbox live like i remember yeah
inhale with halo one
there was this like
weird third-party website you could
connect you'd connect your xbox to the
internet and you could like
search for games through this
third-party website before xbox live was
even a thing
and it felt like
we would go on there and and like i i
could win
like 200 games in a row and it felt like
it was because i had been playing for
years with my brother and his friends
you know constantly against someone else
rather than just the campaign the
campaign's never really interested me
but
um yeah like that's that's pretty much
what we did that's like all i did
growing up
love it love it love it no y'all got
more questions travis you've been
shaking your head i got to know what's
all shaking to hear about i was shaking
my head at goldeneye because i kind of
begrudge anybody who says that that was
a good shooter oh because it's like
it was so good no it really wasn't
though
if you if you could play that game now
you would it's not good now but for it's
time it wasn't even good back then if
you ask people like if you ask people
like oh what was your favorite shooter
they'll be like oh you know back in the
day in the 90s what was your favorite
tutor there'd be like golden eye and
i'll be like i don't think you heard the
question my question was what is your
favorite shooter in the 90s what was
your favorite shooter on nintendo
because if that was the question then
the answer would be of course goldeneye
but that wasn't the question at all
there were much better shooters in the
90s uh and yeah
most of you guys
you could even control with more than
one stick so that's all it sounds like
someone just never got odd job fast
enough no
and listen i played that game a lot and
when i was when i was small even i
thought it was good and then i played a
shooter that wasn't on a nintendo
platform and i went oh right nintendo
doesn't know how to make shooters
i'll
i talk about this all the time with
people dan stapleton is on my side of on
this one he's like dude it is not a good
game people seriously overestimate how
good that game is but uh anyway i i
digress um my question is god
is uh so those were your first shooters
yeah uh
so obviously you started in a very
humble beginnings when it comes to
shooters oh yeah
[Laughter]
so uh my question is when did you get
into good shooters i'm just kidding when
did uh
how did you get you'd like to skip ahead
one minute we'll get to a real question
yeah no no
i didn't get into destiny yeah so that's
my
question
let me think it would have been it was
it was uh second year of destiny one so
basically
it's funny it's a long story so um
i had gone down the rabbit hole of halo
like
probably an unhealthy amount uh halo one
two and three and then
it's funny i actually
i got so consumed that i used to
do in my summer job i was doing a summer
landscaping job i would race home at
lunch
i remember trying to get like level 50
in like every single playlist and i
would race home at lunch beast to get
like a couple matches in before i would
go back to my last job right now
so i i actually um got to a point where
i was like okay this is this is taking
over my life i need to end this and i
just i cold turkey quit all of gaming
like wow completely cold turkey
for years and then wait how long
well
it would have been
yeah i'm trying to think like when oh
god when did like
what would judy um okay
when did advanced
yeah wolf
when did call of duty black ops 3 come
out
because that really got me that's a long
time
wow yeah that came out in 2015 yes
because it was way before that um i want
to say
black ops 2 i is like i barely played
that that was roughly the time frame i
think when i was like okay no no more um
maybe even before then so yeah it was
probably like twenty asking a little
follow-up question
to derail this even further oh dear god
during those years where you weren't
playing games what filled that hole in
your life were you like
doing coke were you right yeah oh what
is that it was it was
could quote that tweet i forget what it
is right that that one guy who's like
man i quit gaming and i started doing
this no um
i think i just became a workaholic
it was probably from like 2010 to 2014
that i didn't game so like four straight
years where i just
i just worked a ton um and saved up as
much money as i could and then wow yeah
i just like
you know what there was one game that i
thought
a little bit of uh we we call it chell
but it's just nhl you know like nhl uh
13 14 but gotcha okay the reason why i
was able to play that i i didn't get
addicted i was like i could play it for
an hour sure go two straight weeks
without without even thinking about it
and then i'd like hop back on and play
it again but okay um
yeah no and then
i honestly it wasn't like i had a hatred
for gaming i was just like i just hadn't
played in so long so i was like it's all
good and then my roommate i moved in
with a buddy of mine
from work actually
and he came home with this game called
destiny and uh again i was not gaming at
all at that time and i'm just watching
him i'm like oh man like this is
i had i didn't even know destiny was it
was a thing i hadn't even like heard of
it i was just watching him play this is
kind of cool but i've never i've never
really been into like pve like campaign
stuff right so i thought like yeah
whatever but then i was watching him do
vaulted class that was pretty cool
and then like crota's end right so i was
watching him like
kind of progress through the whole first
year of destiny um
and then eventually he finally dipped
his toe into pvp so i i literally didn't
even know there was pvp for like eight
months after the release of destiny
you're like oh this is a cool pv game
that's kind of fun to watch oh you can
shoot other people now you have my
attention
yeah and then i remember trying it for
like a weekend and then it was just it
was game over like he never got his
account back i i played on his account
for probably a year straight and then
eventually he was like hey dude like
that's enough like you have to make your
own account it's time for you it's time
for you to buy the bullet buy your own
console and get off of mine
yeah pretty much
and then i was i was hooked like i could
not stop playing um
and then that's also when there there
was like uh
ah man i don't really listen to joe
rogan podcasts anymore he's kind of
taken a taken a turn but
he you he had a podcast on um what was
his name
there's a guy a cs gopro um i think his
name was c9 nothing anyways
he had him on once and that's when i
learned what twitch was so it just kind
of rabbit holed after i had like
learned about pvp and then you know
played on my roommate's account for a
ridiculous amount of time and then i
created my own account and then i then i
saw this podcast with joe rogan and this
guy the cs gopro about twitch and i was
like oh
wow you can watch people like i didn't
even know twitch was a thing
um
by the way you're playing on your uh
friend's account
i think that counts as an account
recurve so bungee ban him please
yeah
he's officially officially outed himself
on the podcast yeah yeah exactly yeah so
yeah we're gonna need to definitely get
that account ban working
that's what's up
a lot of uh a lot of trials on his uh on
his account that's for sure
there you go well
no so i wanted to ask you there's a
there's a gap in there so you got hooked
and then there was uh a change in input
method there was a little bit of a there
was a situation that happened so i got
to hear this story um totally i know
very okay so well so yeah what what's
the deal there's a break what what
happened
yeah a lot of people don't probably know
um
right so then so then after the joe
rogan thing i was like well damn like
i used to be so good at halo 3. i could
totally get good at this game and then i
could stream on twitch
so you know i like hummed and hot over
the course of like late 2015 whatever
and then in 2016 i started streaming on
twitch so pretty like pretty early on i
think relative to
a lot of destiny streamers um
streamed all of
2016. i wasn't big or anything i
probably had around like 50 to 60
viewers per per live stream um
and then no right it was like enough for
me to it was just enough for me to
constantly you know keep coming back and
doing it um but then i actually
i tore all of the tendons in my left
wrist going to my thumb
um
and then that was like
yeah that was pretty devastating so like
here to here
so
i mean it started like right here oh god
anyways um yeah yeah it started like
down here and it went all the way
through um and into like this area here
damn okay dare i uh is it is it a safer
safer podcast story of how that happened
or is this no no
wow oh hockey
yeah it was just a really really bad
injury um
in hockey yeah if it's like gruesome or
i don't know just making sure
yeah no no you're good context um
yeah so
once
well when that happened i then i
i didn't like become depressed but i be
i got pretty pissed because it felt like
i can't use a controller anymore
and like that really opened my eyes like
holy crap
i'm trying to like stream full-time
look at how quickly i just can't stream
anymore so then i like tried like irl
streams
that was a struggle so i actually didn't
play for like
a really good chunk of 2017. so all of
the hype for d2 launched going into d2 i
was still rehabbing uh my left wrist so
i actually missed the launch of of d2
like i didn't play
at all
and that was a double primary error i
was like did you come back for the first
forsaken drew you back in when it got
good again is that right so well so then
in 24 2018
i was like
finally i was able to like work you know
because i also work with a mouse and
keyboard so at work i had like modified
duties for a long time too um
because i just couldn't use my left hand
and like when you're trying to type with
one hand like you'd rather you know put
your fist through a window there's
nothing more more frustrating than
trying to type with one hand
and then switch from the mouse to the
keyboard so anyways um
eventually i was able to like use mouse
and keyboard pain free um i was like i'm
good i'm all rehabbed i'm good and then
i tried using a controller again
just couldn't do it just like after like
40 minutes 30 minutes of using a
controller i just would get shearing
pain again so okay i can't do that
so then but then i was like well i you
know i'm on the computer all day at work
with zero pain maybe i'll just maybe
it's time to learn so i was kind of
forced to learn
mouse and keyboard um
so that would have been yeah that would
have been 2018. and it's funny it was
like similar to the gaming thing it was
a long enough break
i didn't come back to destiny i
became
the boomer of fortnite so i actually got
like
insanely hooked to fortnite so much so
that
i started qualifying for some of those
um
uh like fortnite has like a bunch of
levels of qualifiers to get into
tournaments and whatnot and early on in
in 2018 i was starting to qualify um
for some of those tournaments so then i
basically like flipped the switch and
was like no more like destiny's just out
of my mind completely i was like all in
on fortnite wow
yeah did that for
that was also when i was like i want to
stream again but mixer was blowing up
right
they were kind of faking it
they were fake yeah yeah so microsoft
was like
inflating the numbers on everybody's
streams so that like the social media
around it would look better
kind of crazy actually but
it worked because it got me it got me to
come back to streaming and i was like oh
you know fresh start fortnite i'll try
mixer
and they had this they had this cool
thing
where um they had like this like
algorithm where you know how like you
have front page on twitch yeah
so imagine like front page on twitch
but it constantly switches between
players that are in the top 10 of a
battle royale game so if you were in the
top kind of like fortnight
it would switch to you and you'd have
thousands of people watching you
because it would like pick up that you
were in the top ten and then once you
were done whether you died or you won
the game
you would just move on to the next
person that was in the top ten like
streaming on mixers so it was pretty
cool so i did that
yeah for for a long time um but then
yeah i don't know fortnite just got like
those 13 year olds man
they got some dexterity let me tell ya
yeah um
i yeah i was like really missing destiny
so then i came back to destiny and uh
what what season what give me the video
you know what it i remember
the day i came back
this was the final week of this
menagerie glitch where you could get
them and you could open an ivory chest
like season above
we was eating baby
yeah right yeah yeah yeah chest was nice
yeah back and forth in that chest yeah
you know 10 times so because and i
remember because everyone was like you
got to level up you got to level up
because you got to take advantage of
this so i got to do it for like one
session
but um
so yeah what season would that have been
i don't even remember but that's when i
started up again that's eight right yeah
seems about right yeah i think so
yeah
yeah because shadow keep would have been
like right after that
yes yes yes yes yes so yeah i kind of
joined late honestly um to d2 um
which is probably why you know i don't i
don't feel burnt out at all because i
started a lot lately you've been friends
you've had breaks you've cleared your
head you've seen touched grass
you've done all the right things over
the years to uh
fresh mindset yeah they came back
post-forsaken too like yeah that's a
good that's a good flow yeah you didn't
jump into
the double primary and curse of osiris
when we started our podcast because
we're real smart
uh still going down
still
198 episodes strong that's solid
yeah
that's not real absolute salute man
thank you
like what i wanted to ask you real quick
before you won was just like you know
one thing i just like your technical
approach to the content i remember
that came across your content
i was i was looking at roles and i'm
like yo this peace of mind feels
exceptionally good for some reason oh it
does and i want to want to like refine
it i want to know what's the perk tree
and what's going on what people are
doing and you came up and it's just the
way you broke things down was just
really interesting i started really
looking at your channel and stuff like
that so like just wanted to get real
quick like your approach to your content
you know me as far as why like you chose
that style for doing content that way
because i really like your approach
actually yeah first of all i appreciate
it that's really kind of you um
so thank you yeah i i think
so at work
am i gonna say this so
i am not the brightest i'm not the
brightest guy out there at the place
that i work and i feel like
a lot of the things that we learn at
work i always am like god damn it i wish
they i oh sorry uh
for years at work i was like man like i
wish they would have explained this
better man so like
i just really um insert anything in
destiny to that sentence
yeah but right right and that's like so
my entire career has been kind of like
regurgitating stuff at work
turning around and then teaching
other people at work like i i have i
have staff at work um
and teaching them
like how how to do xyz or how to learn
about what whatever it is and um
i think because i don't get i don't
catch on to things quickly like things
don't come to me easily
i have to just the way i have to like
learn things takes me so long that i
feel like i have
i just have an ability to like kind of
see the perspective of someone who would
have no idea how something works and how
the heck that you should explain it to
them so
um when i started on youtube that's kind
of the mindset that i that i had was
like i want to take complicated things
in the game
see if i can just
make them simple or break them down um
and then it kind of just slowly like
turned into like
yeah like covering a weapon or whatever
it was so um
that's usually my process it's like hey
let me just think if someone has never
used a pulse in this game okay i should
probably tell them it's a pulse rifle
and then they're probably not even
unaware of the fact that there's
several different kinds of pulse rifles
so let's start there and then you know
and
that's usually how i how i uh approach
every video topic
now that makes a difference because
if you make enough content you talk
about games you do enough things people
that are entrenched in whatever it is
tend to take a lot of things for granted
and if you're able to pull yourself far
enough back to remove what you take for
granted and be like
this is a pulse rifle
like how basic can it get and there's
some things that just go over and if you
can get that the basics to someone as
you do it's
it's very important and very it's not an
easy thing for everybody to do well you
can
you can overdo it you can under do it
but if you do it just right it's it's a
talent so it's impressive what you do
that is uh that is one thing that i
struggle with is like
sometimes i'll get comments like okay
like what do you think i just started
i'm like well you know what a lot of
people did just start so you gotta find
that like fine line right but um but
that's the thing is there are so many
people
who don't know it all it's better to
assume generally and i'm the same way
it's like it's i tend to assume people
don't know as much as
you know the person who's going to come
and be like well yeah i knew this
already i'm like that's fine right the
other 20 people who said thank you
are not you so it's fine
yeah exactly yeah no doubt
well
we have some destiny stuff some destiny
stuff to talk about
right
this has been
been a while since it's been this way
that we are
pre-season launch on tuesday
we don't know
story
we don't know activity names activity
size of people
clas enemy race that's involved we know
the date we get the dungeon and
obviously the the patch comes on tuesday
that's mostly it now we have like
sandbox we got iron banner
quality life system stuff but there's a
lot we don't know and i wanted to ask
you guys
what do you think about the
playing the cards close to the chest
basically
i will say it completely clear up front
i have i have asked for this previously
because i didn't enjoy moments like hey
we know kade got killed in the forsaken
trailer
type thing and i wasn't a fan i would
have rather experienced that in the
front on the other side there is the
marketing team selling all of these
copies of a game that they want to sell
and if you do something as big as
killing kade bam you just sold for a
second to a crap ton of people so it's
it's that delicate line bounce now this
is a season person expansion
and this is kind of the balance we're at
like which queen
we knew about the hive that you know got
the light but we didn't know how then we
had the story beat drop that was kind of
a little better balance-ish in my head
curious what you guys think though going
in
probably the idea is tuesday morning i'm
guessing
7 a.m pacific i'm going to be online and
streaming and waiting and
just waiting to see what happens but
it's it's hitting tuesday morning a few
hours before everything goes live so i
wanted to see castle you can go first as
the guest
where are you at in this style of
marketing versus how it's done right
been done previously
yeah i
you know
i'm a big so i totally understand from a
business perspective they need to make
money in order to employ
staff in order to work on the game but i
i so from like from what you know like
how you said killing kade you know that
sells a lot more copies that makes more
money that's better for their resourcing
as a company um but i i kind of prefer
when we don't know like
i usually just like
firing it up and learning what's out
there but that isn't to say i don't like
road maps so i i feel like every season
or expansion
should be somewhat blind
but then followed up with a little bit
of a road map like didn't they do one
for
yeah they did one
i don't remember the last one right for
this sounds like kind of like
like march 13th like so about three or
four weeks later we got a bit of a this
is what's gonna happen on these weeks
ish
yeah so i feel like you know let let
people just kind of dive in for the
first two weeks
and play the game and then you know
maybe maybe in the second week right the
second 12 after after the release or
something like that so that could be
like three weeks whatever but
um you know then give a bit of a road
map like okay you've probably played
through most of the content
here's some road here's a road map
showing you the major pieces but like
you don't even have to include
everything on the road map like a lot of
people like to get
surprised by things it i don't know
twitter always seems so happy when
there's this
like totally new thing that hits the
game
and i mean provided it's good people
love it um of course if it's not good
everyone just immediately brings out
their pitchforks but
yeah i don't know that's kind of my take
on it
my co-hosts where are we at
i gotta see his corporate handcuff
corporate hat
cog coming out or is corporate hat off
right now where are we at
fairly surprising very surprising um
didn't see this coming because i thought
for sure we'd have it this week you know
i pretty much guarantee it and i don't
think i was in a party with dj or
somebody from the clan and then we're
just talking and
you know i'm like yeah get ready man
small reset it's going to come you know
he's going to get the challenge i know
what it is you know and for me it's
always about the story beat the story
beat and the theme always gets me
excited you know and in this case
i'm particularly excited about this
season because with the dungeon and
potential
solar 3.0 arc 3.0 you know that combo in
my mind makes it a meaty season i'm
already excited so now it's okay who's
the player who's the major story focus
and then i can wrap my head around
where the future story is gonna the
overall arctic long story is gonna go so
i'm like damn it and then i'm seeing
them like
really holding this thing the vest like
close
so it's like now i'm like okay
this may be more significant than the
average season because the reason why
i'm saying that is i feel like
they i mean not that they can't be
secretive
but they would like to market it right
so i feel like whatever they're holding
on to is very dear to maybe the story be
and travel i'm gonna ask you this i want
to set you up with it because
me and you have kind of been of the
mindset
which
traditional bungie this will be a
self-contained thing
that's not gonna affect the overarching
thing coming off a witch queen right but
i'm like why are you so sick if you this
secret if it's almost like right and we
gonna transition from broke witness
stuff more like why are you holding on
to this so i would give it to you
because i am really shocked by this i
did not see this coming i thought we'd
have it by now
yeah um
i'm sort of in between like i i kind of
don't care i just want the game to be
good right like i just want your content
to be good but
i will say uh
when you don't show your game it either
means that
uh you don't feel that you need to or
that you're afraid to
and that's like as a reviewer you know
when i when i don't get a code for a
game early and uh you know they give it
to me like the day the game comes out
i'm always like oh this game is probably
going to suck right because they they
would have given me the game the code as
early as they could have if otherwise
right or maybe they just didn't finish
it yet they gave it to me because they
finished the game on the day it came out
you know which is kind of common
nowadays
um
but uh i don't know if bungie has that
problem right like if if they didn't
show anything for the seasonal reveal
and then it just showed up and it was
like one of the worst seasons ever right
just had like a random six-person match
made activity and nothing you'd be like
oh well no wonder they didn't show
anything like this is garbage right
but
yeah so
i'm kind of i don't really know what to
expect it's gonna be one of the other um
but i don't i don't expect it'll be that
the season's bad so if it's not bad then
that means they must be pretty confident
in it or they've realized that
you can announce ex with games as a
service it's not uncommon to
not really announce what the expansion's
out until people can play it now that
way they see a trailer and they go oh
there's a new thing and destiny let me
log on now rather than
getting the uh
they don't have to build hype and try to
sell retail copies before and all that
stuff they're just trying to like get
people to log on when they see the new
the hot newness so maybe this is their
model for seasons in between the large
annual releases you know annual releases
they hype up
before it comes out and then the seasons
they kind of just let you know once it's
already out i would be okay with that
and i trust bungie enough to know that
it's not gonna
be for you know the other reason that we
usually don't see trailers which is that
they're afraid to show you gameplay or
whatnot i don't think that we're in any
uh any danger of that with this
particular title but it is you know
transparency
is something that i sort of advocate for
so i'm a little on the fence on this one
yeah so you know it would be
terrifyingly bad as if they were like
the big secret is solar 3.0 and then
they're like oh crap
they know they know it's coming like but
they're like too far invested they're
like no just keep it a secret yeah i
mean
what if the big secret was that they
couldn't get solar 3.0 out in time and
it's like
that
[Laughter]
well the thing is starfield also didn't
show anything right that's why that that
delay doesn't bother me it's more like
the
when you see
when you see the product and it either
isn't what you were expecting or they uh
you you you risk the um anticipation of
what your product is going to be
spiraling out of control uh when when
you do that method so people might have
their expectations too high right like
cog is now like oh if they're not
showing anything it must be this hugely
consequential season and if it's not
then we're going to be like oh damn
maybe they should have just shown us
something that way we that way we didn't
run away with expectations they were
yelling bungie from yeah that's the
thing
and that's kind of what it's been
interesting before which queen came out
i think they were doing it again they've
been doing it again i've seen some of
those coming again yeah so they're
popping off again on twitter like they
are so light yeah i mean those are those
are individuals though they might be
looking at at destiny in 2024 i have no
idea you know i mean you never know what
they're in reference to but that's the
narrative team
and i said this like in a previous show
has specifically been hyped for
like we're really hyped i i was hired
for this thing finally whatever i wrote
is coming out this season and they're
hyped for it and
that for the narrative team especially
when we heard issues about you know
narrative and story and lore and
mindling games and the stuff you went
through previously now seeing the
narrative team be like just
in cogs words outside talking about it
um it's exciting because
we got a really cool tight story in
season of the risen
way better than season of the undying
so when we've made leaps and bounds from
where we were for these seasons before
and this was the season that launched
with one of like literally the best
destiny extension also got a damn good
tight season to go with it was it the
best season that's debatable because you
know it was cool but it was a little
shorter some good guns different
activity but it was a decent season
paired with a great expansion
and then the key is the season that
follows the expansion
needs to keep that train going and we've
already seen the story beats going we
had the story the seasons last year go
through and hit with chosen
then splicer and then lost being like
okay we got that narrative we got the
big hit with witch queen what are they
going to do to lead into lightfall which
feels like this
near cataclysmic moment outside of final
shape which was you know feels like
we're going to fight the witness what is
that in between moment what builds to
that and if they're actually in some
coherent narrative to that
i want to see what that is but the
narrative team being excited is really
cool but as you guys have said if
something isn't quite right like they're
building up the hype building up the
height and then just like the tea kettle
just like fizzles out in the end there's
no like big whistle it's just like boo
like and it doesn't quite hit like solo
3.0 it's like it's fine the guns are we
log in and there's nothing to be excited
about
they could learn a tough lesson as well
and that's one of those moments where we
just have to see it is
i can't think of i'm not i know this
isn't the only time they've done this
but it is for the seasons like the day
of trailer does make some sense as
travis said for the live game
like you see the trailer log in today
and get this thing that actually makes
sense i didn't actually i hadn't
actually thought of that because
it is
this is the reminding people who got the
expansion the
deluxe edition to say hey just in case
you forgot or you put it down you've
been playing something else bam we got
new stuff for you you already have the
deluxe edition now it's time to come
back in and see what's next and that's
just going to be a live update that
morning so i'm excited to see what's
coming i need to step out just for a
quick minute you're good yeah brother
you're good you're good
yeah man i'm excited i'm definitely
excited for that let's see how they they
handle this thing man this is unique
territory you know yeah so i like it
yeah it's just going to be
it's going to be an early morning on
tuesday and then a long day
and then we also know the week is going
to be a pretty good way
presumably a long day depends on what we
get seasonal activity season is just one
cut scene
no new activity
you know i can probably bet that it's
not that
what if they didn't show you a trailer
because the trailer would have given
away all of the content well i got it
all the time this is all they have for
us
that's it you log in
you see whatever verse has and then
you're out
that's the only content you need it's
not that's my weekly ritual in destiny
these days
i do be checking
tests
i see if um
what's his face has uh has arrived yet
what's his name
in church i see offend churches
yeah if he's not there i log off it's my
destiny ritual uh speaking of everest
did you guys see the new shader this
week your rgb rotating color action
yeah that's pretty cool yeah so it's a
shader that works on
guardian games armor
most specifically the zur egg ship like
the zurb meteorship and it literally
just cycles through colors like rgb and
a computer it's this just constant
cycling of color that rotates through
it doesn't work on
the solstice armor that's still linked
to your class glow but the guardian
game's armor has this rotation like the
guardian game ships the sparrow anything
that has that
glow to it this thing will have kind of
a pretty neutral background and the
colors just like cycle so that's just a
unique shader to it just one of those
it's for bright dust so if you want to
get it or not yeah i gotta go pick that
up
yeah i thought it was pretty sweet yeah
it was a surprise to see them get a
little creative with those because i'd
like to see more of that type of stuff
especially
what else we got guys try to look like a
monkey or what
we will get to that hold put a pin in
that one but yeah that is
uh we did get a swab this week
um i talked about this in my video and
i'm gonna say it again here um over the
weekend terrible things happened in
multiple parts of the country
and
shout out to
bungie for they put their statement out
basically as to what happened and
um basically relaying that they're
trying to support
you know anybody who may have been
affected by it the b herd pin is back it
was the one that was for black lives
matter before they've got their black at
bungie inclusion club all of these
pieces are they're putting it to the
front of the store so if you do buy the
pin for the next year any profits from
that are going to go to the southern
poverty law center um that is an
organization that works to
basically stop all of these type of
events from happening and stopping the
online pieces that can feed into those
so if you want to look into it if you
decide to donate that is totally up to
you but it was just over the weekend
terrible situation number one and then
it was the next day i think in
california on both coasts i was just
like damn
so it was really really it was a painful
weekend i was like i don't know if
anybody else you but it was just it was
the more information we got about the
one in buffalo especially i don't know
if anybody else wants to say anything
about that or not
no it's pretty i'll jump in it's pretty
rough times in the country right now and
um
yeah i mean the thing that i always find
interesting to relate us into video
gaming is just that you know bungie's
been consistent they're not going to
back down it's um it almost reminds me
of when people you know see the meme
shut up and dribble and they're like
nope we're using our social media we're
using our accounts to speak out and
kudos to them you know they choose not
to be run i think something else i saw
which was very interesting that someone
was like i wonder if bungie is going to
change his position now to do the
ownership at sony and yeah they were
like yeah nothing is stopping us so
salute to them they've always been on
the front line with stuff like this and
it it's cool to see you know in my
opinion that the company is gonna you
know operate to the beat of their own
drum i'm always a fan of that so yeah
so i don't know they're amazing for that
really really do love that
absolutely
yeah so i did not want to skip over that
because tragedy happened multiple times
over the course of the weekend and
bungie's trying to
you know do the right thing and honestly
i'm going to get a comment about it on
my channel again but i put a video in
the twab talking about this in the
beginning i read their statement about
it that's all my comments are right now
it's just about that type of thing and
it's like do you talk about it do you
not but then it's for me it's just to a
point to where
there's very little i always feel i can
do but if you ignore it i feel like it's
worse so it's the moment
it's hard if you don't talk about it
then
like how how can anything change like uh
you know
i don't know yeah you hundred percent
like it's it's important and i also
think like
so the company i don't tell people like
what i do or where i work but you know
the company that i work at is like
similar to bungie they're not a
developer for a game story but like
similar to bungie with this type of
thing um
they're huge on on you know being open
and vocal about this stuff and like if
they aren't
and other companies won't you know like
i
once when some companies see other
companies do it it it pushes them to do
it um
so yeah i don't know i i think it's i
think it's awesome i love that the
company that i work for does it
and uh hopefully more and more continue
to you know push to support it
like i said this last time this came up
but
uh it's important to note that even
companies that don't make public
statements are still political
organizations that do political things
they just
don't typically talk about it
i would rather have a company tell me
where it stands personally if it's going
to be putting its thumb on the scale
with money or influence or what have you
and totally in bungie in bungie's case
it seems like largely the people
the employees are feel like their voices
are represented by the company they work
at rather than what you see at other
places where people are saying some very
weird political statements and internal
emails and sending that out to the
employees to uh
yeah that's the whole platform had a bad
look this week i'm like yeah yeah i
would just say we're talking about sony
by the way like yeah very high up had
some really poor choice of words
yeah so i just feel like um
not not not being political isn't on the
menu
that's they're people right they're
they're run by people that who have
money their employees work there who
have their own personal stake in the
world and its politics and so not
you know covering up your eyes and ears
and mouth are not really an option so
the question really is do you prefer to
be transparent or not transparent that
those are your options right and i think
bungie's philosophy is probably the one
i would prefer so yeah i was like i
agree i mean aries said it in chat
nothing changes if nothing changes um
lord darius shout out to him you were
literally one of the ones in my comments
when i went to go look after the video
was up for a little while and i was
getting ready and doing the stuff i was
doing around my house i looked in and
saw him replying in there and
and it's just the idea it's like this
was a terrible thing that happened
period
like that shouldn't happen and if
they're trying to step out and say hey
these are things that are happening in
the world right now this is why it
happened and they're we're trying to
find a way to help stop these things
happening that's not political that's a
terrible thing that happened
period and just the fact that they're
trying to do something to help that
doesn't mean bungie stay in your lane
and just make your video games or
whatever they're standing up for
something that they believe is a good
thing and i think there's nothing wrong
with that and same to you guys in chat
and all of you guys saying it's like
the discussions need to happen and it it
can be a discussion i am totally fine in
comments you have a civil discussion
keep it that way you can have now
granted i don't know where you're going
to come on the
hopefully you're not like supporting
this one but again if you are then you
probably don't belong following my
channel and that's a choice but on this
one it's just one of those things that
a discussion can be allowed if you have
a civil discussion and that's one thing
travis you and i kind of talked about
offline before is like discourse is hard
to have about anything right now
so if you can't have a discussion it's
hard to
find a compromise come to a middle grant
anything like on different issues and
stuff like this this was just a bad
situation
and it's just and it's really sad and
bungie's trying to do something to
support it that seems like a pretty big
win in my book and that's my opinion as
well so
anyway gotta get the somber stuff out of
the way but it's gotta be done
now
shout out to the warlocks
looks like you got that w
i mean how much support from bungie you
know
i mean i don't know how much it was
rigged i don't know how much it was
processing i know my titan brothers are
processing right now this is tough for
you guys and i understand you know
you're used to running it full head
first into things and get in your way
but this time you better against the
brick wall that is the warlocks and
shout out to the warlocks that did the
right thing that now we're back to the
natural order of things and it feels
good
just for travis's face right there that
was worth it
yeah exactly
his face was worth the price permission
but look man it was it was great it was
good to see and i just can't wait to see
what when did we get the prize where
does it go down yeah i want the full
celebration of what the pomp and
circumstance i want flowers rose petals
trumpets bearing i want warlocks all
across the world put their hands up it's
our day it's on days guys yeah
okay
what did you guys think
just straight up blunt like what do you
guys think of guardian games
how they do it
i'll tell you
what they could do differently well i
was like we've we actually covered a
decent amount of this last time i asked
these two no no no that's what i was
gonna add turn around and ask you that
because we had some of ours i asked
these two last time how much they had
been playing guardian games
basically none
i've been doing zero yeah
so see and you contributed to your own
downfall yeah
yeah i know shout out to the world
i'm just joking from the guy who didn't
contribute to his free w either
i was playing banana i was playing oh
you're like oh look look what i did
nothing for you i contributed was that
beep i did my part
i
put one medallion in
exactly
i think was just saying it's like okay
so now everybody's got one so next year
it's some kind of tie breaker when they
refresh it like
that could be a thing it sounds like
when we're getting to events like
solstice of heroes or solstice now
is gonna have a little bit of a tweak
and maybe when guardian games comes
around maybe we will and again we talked
about ideas before castle i don't know
what you've got we talked i mean the
idea of guardian games and as a class
battle 3v3 v3 or something like that for
pvp or 4v4 v4 for pvp like three points
three teams who's gonna come out and
whatever victories like part of it could
be crucible not just you know grinding
monotonous strikes for points and
cheesing points and all that stuff so
what do you think about the event what
would you change we've hashed our ideas
out a little bit
no 100 like
put warlocks against titans and then
titans against hunters and then hunters
against warlocks like you could do yeah
like
you could do like uh maybe a rumble
where it's like
you get put into a rumble against
you know one of the other two classes or
there's like two hunters two titans and
two
two um
warlocks and then it adds the points
from that match
you know like okay that maybe the titan
top fragged but the other titan bottom
fragged and then so it's like okay you
did be kind of okay because you add the
top
score and the bottom score and that's
sort of whatever but the two warlocks
you know they maybe they were in the
middle
like i'm with you i just feel like
there's so many ways that they could
just make it
or maybe it's impossible from like a
developing standpoint like
not a game developer right i got a
thought that that's an electric caster
and um trav help me here because
forza horizon 5 when you join like a
convoy and there's like team racing and
like
they actually have at the end of the
race is like like if me you me and trav
are on one team and like there's like
point scoring that is compiled for the
team based on positioning as well i know
like i said we're not a developer i
don't act like it's so easy to do but
they just i would you can they gotta do
something man to make it truly the
spirit of the game but continue i had
interrupted you no no you're good like
the only cool thing about the event is
loading into the tower and seeing the
flag it ends there like i i have zero
interest in clicking on those playlists
and this i feel guilty even saying this
i'm literally on
team titan i i was really lucky there
was a guardian are you guys even aware
that there's a guardian cup going on
right now maybe yeah maybe you aren't
okay
but a lot of people
a lot of people aren't aware that there
was this guardian cup um
and datto was the the team captain for
titans in for north america there's it's
like region specific um
but yeah and you know i was lucky enough
to join their team and it was like holy
crap i need to get i need to get my
power level up to make sure i'm ready
for this but
um
you know even that was like
it's just it was just us doing
activities together which was a blast
but if there was a way that they could
have like put
you know datto's team up against
fallout's team in like
some type of like a live scoring event
where it's like one versus the other
again i don't really know how they would
do it but i just feel like
the way it's currently being done is so
boring like there's just i don't know i
have no interest in doing it
it's yeah it's frustrating i mean i've
spent a decent amount of time in there
i've been kind of goofing around with
soloing to try and see if i can get i
got top 10 soloing the strike playlist
but i already have my issues with that
how come you always you always call me
out for bragging [ __ ] but never when he
does it oh no he'd be flopped
he's okay
he's okay i don't know he'd be flexible
you know my ray team is me true vanguard
and yeah you know i try not to say that
stuff by the way and you guys are like
no no you have to say the names and i'm
just trying to say my raid team and
you're like no no tell us all the names
we have to hear them out loud again say
the names i'm out here trying to
fight back against the stigma that ign
reviewers can't play video games well
and you know i'm just i'm out here you
know trying to get a flex every now and
again you know just
to fight back against that stigma
uh so i don't know i feel like it's fair
game to call you out you you streamer uh
wow that's amazing
anywho no my issues with strike scoring
are the way they set it up they did fix
the
you know killing yourself over and over
and over and then rezzing people like
that was something that was exploited
but the idea that time is not
incentivized like if you're fast there's
no bonus for being fast and still
killing everything there's no benefit
for that right now they changed the
strike from uh vial of i don't even
remember the name of the strike what's
the whole name of the strike vial of
birthplace birthplace of the vial got it
um okay
because there's a point where you can
just spawn enemies until your time's up
take that score go beat the boss and
that's how you get your time and you can
farm that one for a bunch the idea is
there's no benefit for time
fast which again if you can kill
everything survive and actually be
faster you should get some benefit to
that the whole
dance before you do a finisher for so
many
that
before you finish anything gotta go i
don't like the idea of like hey let me
play tactical but let me dance in the
middle of a strike before i go
a finisher like i understand like lucent
finisher
um the lucent finisher piece is
a good thing because that actually helps
you get ammo and like finishing the
champions is not a bad thing but that
shouldn't be like worth ten thousand
points and if i could kill a guy it's
worth two
and no new rad i'm not i don't know on
that one so anyway i can have my own
opinions but hey i could agree with
somebody that's fine
um
shout out to necromancer zeal who's
getting the guardian games mug
that's a thing that that might happen
and then shout out real quick to rel he
was saying solar arc what do we want
we'll get to that um
thank you for the super chat where i get
them i want my chalice so if you light
enough of the platinum torches at the
end of it you just have to do two of
them but if you light enough platinum
torches you should be able to get the
mug that's the earliest thing you can
get
uh the mug is like very ridiculous and
just over the top but kind of in a way
that makes me kind of want it but yeah
it's like the idea of strike scoring is
here you need to emote and then finish a
champion but if you finish a champion
it's 10 000 points if you shoot a
champion it's like not nearly as much
and if that's the efficient way it's
just a weird
setup because they don't
i understand like chaining things or
using your abilities totally fine but
not everything feels balanced and start
scoring i would like to see strike
scoring
be used in another way i'm not saying
like strike scoring fixes the boring
vanguard playlist because you still go
in there mo over everything you've done
for whenever you play it but find a way
to use strike scoring in another way and
if it comes around once a year
it needs some tweaks so for me guardian
games is it's fine but it's
strike scoring needs a little bit more
or i would say a lot more love before
it's in a good place and it'd be cool to
see it in the game you know could you
imagine just like nightfall leaderboards
just for entertainment value and
yeah just and if they could actually get
it to a point where it's not cheesed
which i know is hard because we're gonna
exploit everything we always do but if
they could ever get to a point where
like you know the nightfall this week
you have a leaderboard and you're in the
top then maybe you get something i don't
know but that's something they could do
and right now he's so huge yeah right
now it's just gonna be here for the
event and leave and then we have no idea
if it's gonna come back any time so
that's my favorite
what do you think like people who play
call of duty you know while there's tons
of games but like
you know it's like friends that play
call of duty
half the time they're playing so that
they can pass their buddy on the leader
on the friends list to filter the
leaderboard
within the game you know it's like
leaderboards can do so much imagine if
guardian games had like
um not like uh what am i trying to think
i think of like all you know like
all-star games or all-star matches in in
sports so like with hockey it's like
you've got like your fastest skater
you've got your you know your most
accurate shooter your artist slap shot
so on and so forth
what if they had like
you know the the fastest
person or team to beat x strike or y
activity and it was in game and it was
like warlocks are currently leading the
way
with this like this uh you know time
time completion
i just feel like so many titans you know
and it's like the only way to actually
like register or like go into it is like
three titans you know that's right right
you want to have it all yeah you define
yeah okay you want to take the top score
you got to get two other buddies who are
also on titan and then you got to go
into the strike as three titans
and try and beat this and because i felt
like in week one of the guardian cup um
when like that'll kind of like split us
up into these these two groups to do
lost sectors that you know he was
thinking that might be the fastest way
to like just get medallions anyways um
you know i'm i'm like a lost sector like
that's kind of boring but whatever um
but it actually was a lot of fun because
the three of us were just constantly
trying to better ourselves and see how
fast you know it was like the first run
we did in like three minutes the next
round was like 2 30. the next one was 2
10 and then
we like two hours in our for our two
hour time slot it like flew by because
we were constantly trying to optimize
and see if we could break one minute
and i just feel like people need
something like that to chase
and then i don't know how you do the
scoring but like some somehow like
whatever team wins this
thing the fastest skater which could be
emulated as like the fastest completion
of this strike
gets points for the warlocks or some
something like that but
no definitely needs a rework to make it
actually competitive between the classes
it's just the the the nitty-gritty and
then hopefully they take the feedback
because you know it's just been rinse
and repeat this thing and it's not
really competing it's like travis said
it best last year was it's like this he
said it's the most like you said it was
a passive aggressive competition
yeah
no dunking medallions
[Laughter]
like perfectly said you're killing
fallen at the other
which is kind of how the olympics works
actually now that i think about it
but yeah it's like it's the point where
it's like okay i see what they're trying
to do but the idea of what guardian
games could be so much more
it just depends on i don't know how much
resources they have
and what it would take but it's an event
that has so much potential in all of our
eyes it's just if it can get there so
yeah it's funny that uh
they're they don't have a leaderboard in
pve
and they don't have a competitive
anything in this game
and so it's sort of like they're just
not really like maybe they're afraid of
doing the competitive part i would love
it if you guys got
leaderboards in pve
and then we're constantly talking about
how
they'll never make it so that you can't
choose those leaderboards and therefore
you know it's an imperfect system and
then we'll be like this is how pvp
people feel about the balancing the meta
yeah well they'll never get to a
balanced meta it's like okay but that
doesn't mean it's not worth trying
they'll never get to a fully non-cheesed
pve meta all right well
then i guess we should just cancel
destiny because it'll never be perfect
such a stupid argument anyway yeah last
thing though 1550 match made everywhere
just do it like the legend stuff should
have matchmaking on it this is proof put
it in there if you want to be optimal
you take friends with you or you do it
solo and go crazy like some people do if
you if you want to get through it you
can still get the prisms you can still
get chances at nightfall weapons even if
they're low
legend matchmaking turn it on nightfalls
don't care what like same thing for
legend psyops that should have
matchmaking that still bugs the hell out
of me so
hopefully that sticks and maybe this was
a trial cross our fingers we'll see but
yeah i'm with you last point i just want
to i love castle's idea
of with the forced warlock teams titan
teams and i could just see a scenario
like pvp could you imagine doing three
threes that it's like all titans versus
all warlocks and like that's cool you
know like i just want them to really
dive into it that's all yep yep
well we also got to be possible yeah it
does feel like it is it's just if they
can and are willing to put the resources
to it again we don't know what the
priorities in the studio are probably
hard to know that we never will
but it does seem like events are going
to get a bit of an update
so we've got the fact that events are
going to get an event card
uh that's basically going to be kind of
like it fails kind of like in destiny 1
when you got those little books for
things the books exactly exactly yeah
the little books and it seems like we
have seasonal challenges above your
quest log there's probably going to be
this little like mini book up there
click on it open it up it's like a
little
event card challenge thing that you're
going to go through and knock out all
the list of objectives the same way you
do seasonal challenges i like that
also one of the biggest things it's not
time gated
i like that as well the seasonal
challenge or the event card they say
all of the challenges are available from
the get-go you will be able to do it
anytime you want to i like the fact that
they don't time-gate these things
because even right now what if you were
going for the ten percent but you had a
vacation on the third week
guess you aren't going to get that third
one so
those aren't gonna be time-gated which
feels like a good thing
solstice
is just gonna be that there is no of
heroes anymore
they're going to do a little bit of a
twist with the european aerial zone so
we are going back in there
but they said there's going to be
something called bonfire bash they say
where guardians will be building and
stoking what can only be described as a
pair causal bonfires while the enemies
of summer fun including taken cabal hive
and fallen will be attempting to crash
the party and extinguish the fires this
is their way to build lore around horde
mode because in your mission to guard
the flames wave after wave of incoming
enemies we made it easier to transverse
the eaz as well so they've added some
like good traversal stuff but basically
kind of sounds like he is he's gonna get
a horde mode ish does this sound
exciting to you guys
yeah i mean i'm thinking my minds
elsewhere i just think that to me this
is like
i would be shocked if it's not solar 3.0
bonfires
solstice like like it is literally set
up for you to give a solo 3.0 bungie
like this is hilarious to me if it's not
i'll be shocked right now that's what i
had to say to continue no no yeah it's
like i think solar's
i'm i'm honestly wanting solar because i
want my hammers to get my tweaks i want
so i'm biased i want solar 3.0 i want to
sell it too 95 i'm sure it's gonna be
solar as well so
uh would you guys think about eaz and
all this stuff
are you guys excited for a horde mode do
you think it can even be a horde mode is
it just the same thing we've done before
where you guys at
i feel like every mode in destiny is a
horde mode
was the was the last eaz not not a horde
mode
where you just had to travel around and
kill things
yeah pretty much what is it play the
mystery chess game at the end yeah
god please fix that let's do a strike
okay now wait uh by your ghost while you
fight hordes of enemies okay
cool
raid all right it's in the second phase
of the raid the horde of enemies comes
at you cool
um yeah i don't i don't know um
i mean i'll i'll wait and see but i'm
just i have so little faith in the
seasonal events right now like none of
them have really pulled me in for a
couple of years now so
we'll see
castle are you
are you tuning in for the seasonal
events are you tuning out for the
seasonal events uh you know
i'm
wish i could say yes i don't usually pay
too much attention let
being being in this guardian cup kind of
forced me to learn about guardian games
and obviously i've known about it for
like ever you know
since it's been a thing but
this was the first time that i was like
actually learning how it works and
interested in you know how it works and
yeah i don't know not many of them
pulled me in unfortunately um
i
i'm one of those people on twitter who
wishes their time and resources went
towards making more crucible maps
how dare you castle
yeah
improve this other aspect of the game
that's neglected what's wrong with you
don't you know this is the pve 80 game
you're in a good company though cause we
all would like some of that
yeah
yeah i don't know i i um
some of them have been good but i i
don't usually get super drawn in by them
um
largely because
like not not all of them but so often
they're just so heavy on the pve side
and i'm i'm just like just let me
let me acquire and complete and do and
contribute via pvp please i feel like
crimson doubles remember we had grooves
and devils i feel like
remember when we had any seasonal events
that were pvp i feel like tomorrow they
could announce a new seasonal event
called like head-to-head death match and
it would be like a pve mode where you
you know go around collecting moats of
light or something like it's just crazy
to me okay yeah
the doubles though found the valentine's
day double stuff yeah
some analytics with that event
must have like ruined whatever they hope
to be like hey we're going to get pvp
engagement and like
they lost 95 of their player base on the
seasonal event we're like oh this is
because something had that's my only
thing i can come up with because as you
said castle
so much pve on like next to everything
and you're like there can't be like a
and the same thing we talked about in
guardian games there can't be a pvp
anything for this like nothing for three
years we've had this and there's no pvp
pieces at all shout out real quick to
charles phelps for the dollar super chat
by the way
shouldn't it be called guardian game
yeah if there's only one game that
you're really competing against it's
just strikes it's not really games right
i think there have to be multiple games
to call it guardian games just make a
pvp
game yeah see black road and tune it out
pvp that's what happens because this is
what my theory is from d1
if you remember they bungee was more
adventurous with with kind of infusing
pvp activities into questions people
hate being forced into pvp stuff yeah i
remember when you had remember when you
got thrown in d1 and you had to go in
and you had to get people killed
and that's what it is and it's like the
void kills
yeah now granted they may have been a
bit aggressive or very specific with
certain things but i have to admit like
some of those things actually made me
better and then play pvp and then end up
liking pvp because prior to that i was
in that pve mindset i don't want to do
it whatever whatever and i think for
whatever reason we know they're very
analytical driven they're very data
driven they must have said uh we can't
we see the crimson days numbers and we
can't do a pvp only event oh god we
can't you know say and i think they just
been gun shy ever since and i also think
yeah i'm very curious i'm very curious
about
srl as well because
it's a competitive mode like do they did
they see engagement go down i thought
the ball was quite i loved srl man i did
that more
i was like hell bent to be first and
like every race was and i was like
trying to be like oh i got a better time
here i was trying to get like top oh
yeah i was actually quite competitive in
that i really tried and i missed it it
was fun
for another flex
going uncalled out
which one which one i can say i tried in
a mode my dude
is amazing in srl and i don't hear a
word from cog about it i just
yeah you said like he was the best at
this
all right over here in the uh
playlist we're gonna go ahead and push
i'm just happy he even played it i was
i'm shocked he's playing that guy
his participation was happening i can't
imagine being a try hard but you can you
know talk about you know
i know with ease flexes that was that
was boy i was i was taken back but i'll
i'll do better at documentation
i gotta catch cog off guard every so
often that way he doesn't get on me so
correct he did a good job there i do
think yeah like
ah it's got to be analytics driven like
you're like you said maybe the doubles
weekend was just like so abysmal
but then like
how how
do you guys think it'd be really bad if
they just
came out and told us that they were like
hey by the way we tried this thing
and like none of you played so that's
why we're
you know we're reluctant to try it again
yeah but
to travis's point is at the very at the
bare minimum it should be optional right
there should be for the people who do
not want to do strikes is like look i
want to live in pvp yeah let me achieve
my goal my way and they've been getting
better over the last couple of seasons
even with quests and bounties where
they'll give you
this or this right yeah they've got to
do better with the pvp community because
they're like i remember seeing so many
posts just like guys like you know guys
we've had on ill physics we've had many
people on at some point that were pvp
amazing like look
y'all don't care about us let's just be
honest like you you're saying
for sure i mean yeah yeah also they
don't try nearly as hard with pvp events
like if they do crimson doubles and they
put like the lowest effort no rewards no
like new maps or anything then they'll
be like well it didn't it didn't do well
and really the only reason it possibly
couldn't have done well is because it's
a pvp mode so let's just can it and it's
like right it has nothing to do with
effort level it feels like a particle
situation easy for the fourth year in a
row with the same reskin you know level
it's just like dude
you guys
you tell me that was working amazingly
the feedback was just so incredible you
had to do it the third year in a row
like i just don't believe you
i don't believe the infinite forest
season the
festival of the lost was was so good
that you deserved doing it a third year
in a row i just don't believe that
that's true so yeah i agree with you
it's it's a self-fulfilling prophecy for
yeah that's what i was going to say is
like the idea that like we we had this
thing one time it's like if you don't
put the effort into the event nobody's
going to want to do it and that's the
thing is they give so much on one side
every so often make the pvp people happy
you gotta balance it and i think finally
either teams move around or shift it or
priorities or whatever we're finally got
you know the big joe growth drop we've
got like rift is finally coming we are
getting one map like the train is barely
leaving the station look how barely here
we are and you just give us some crumb
and a bit i told you
the trump started to leave the station
it's got a long ways to go
but it was like blows my mind it's it's
barely started but it's like
i think the train is headed on a uh on a
railroad track with all the pvp players
that are tied down to the railroad
that's right yeah
that's where that train is going
usa castle no it's just crazy because
it's like we you
we had it in d1 like yes we did how on
earth
can you go i mean god this was real this
was launched sorry i don't mean i'm
gonna sound off yeah
we are coming up on
five years
this this october
and we've had control
pretty much just control like yeah okay
fine you got rumble you got mayhem here
and there but like
how on earth does a company
think that that's okay to just have
control like
halo cat capture the flag you know like
there are oddball like maybe it's the
company that made that too
sonic this is that
gun game with exotics are you kidding me
that writes itself
that right it's insane
not to interrupt but i like halo trav we
play halo i was so
enamored when fiesta came i forgot i'm
like fiesta's such a cool mode i'm like
could you imagine we just start with
something we start off with rat king and
then i got exactly oh then you get
vigilant so like just even on a base
level there's so much they can do sorry
castle continue no it's just it it like
it baffles me that like
that that's they just they did they
completely gave up on pvp
i don't know i just think pvp if they
had like all these things like oddball
capture the flag fiesta all of these
different game modes oh
oh my god the guy wouldn't even be hard
to add either like maybe that maybe
that's super like arrogant of when you
know and uh
[Music]
backseat backseat game developer you
know true
situation you can already turn off
emotes so you can limit like third
person stuff there they already lock you
into certain things with scorched
so they can be like this is the
government
every other game doesn't have a hard
time with it and we've had private
matches where you can make your own
custom rule sets and stuff and i just i
feel like they have the tool set to do
it of course they do that it's like they
choose that bugged me the whole whenever
we got private matches whenever that
actually launched it bugged me because
it was private you can play against
somebody that's not custom games and it
never was there's no you know guns if
you could mess with the sandbox can you
imagine the fun stuff that you would
make up might be like a forge of course
yeah
destiny will not get if destiny gets
halo before forge halo should just shut
down but yeah
like
you know in the whole like trials um
you know we're taking it down so that we
can really do it right
yeah take it away i'm sorry like it's
you came back with the same game
like
it's still just go win you know x number
of games to get to the lighthouse it's
like what what is that how is that a
rework i get it like okay we have these
you know we have these bounties we have
different reward systems we have
you know tokens like okay fine cool
that's it one guy like a year and a half
to make that because they have one guy
on the trials team
and that was it
so that's one dude i'm joking that's
mine
yeah i just and like part of me like so
some someone who's competitive i'm
actually not a big fan of elimination i
i trials is cool like don't get me wrong
d1 trials was amazing d2 charles has had
its incredible moments elimination leads
to a lot of um like clutch and hype
moments okay but part of me is just yeah
again it was like you guys reworked it
like no it still is just the same thing
go win seven games go to lighthouse
elimination are you a forced competitive
guy what what's your what's your sweet
spot
uh just skirmish like i in day one i
just lived in skirmish non-stop um you
know it's just three three v three i
actually think like the comp game mode
um
whispers so long house
just had a different point structure so
it wasn't like one point for a kill um
it depended on like what the kill was
and stuff like it was just a points
based
um no resistance there basically but
there was no right
okay sorry sorry to derail you i just i
forgot i just want to know if there was
res in skirmish or no yeah no there were
yeah yeah you can get points
yeah yeah i remember it now it's coming
back it's coming back
half the amount of time
like it's just so cool
yeah yeah yeah i forgot bye bye
no no you're good it's just to me again
it was like what have we had in five
years we've had we've had control we've
had trials that's it we've had control
and elimination
and then they sprinkled you know mayhem
and um
well okay rumble's a staple you
keep you forget about the scorch cannon
mode so you're right team scorpio which
was like accidental just like sure yeah
like and you know what cool for a
weekend awesome fun but like yes they're
trying something you know
like it blows my mind so with trials i
just felt like and you know the the
problem is like
i have this feeling like if they made
trials not elimination if they tried
something else that the community would
freak because it isn't like that
nostalgia like that sorry that nostalgic
d1 trials which i don't know if i've
really understood
part of me is like
memories great memories are
are supposed to be great memories like
why can't we make new memories in a new
game mode why can't we have like you
know call it trials of whatever
and just
totally different don't make it
elimination make make come up with the
new trials a new game mode
that is they did though
in their
and it is a forge mode where you make
your own multiplayer because
bungie is having trouble doing it let
the community do it right yeah yeah
like dim
you know that's right
they just let they just let the
community make the most amazing tool
ever no let us do that for pvp
but yeah these are the tough discussions
look glad you got it off because we've
been saying about supremacy i forgot bro
i did it bro it's been so long since we
got mold exactly i forgot that we had
modes taken away
i forgot about that i was like oh yeah
we used to play that
we just have a bunch of mods yeah
and like for for me i'm actually it's
funny i made the joke about like new
maps um
i actually don't care that i think it's
crazy how we haven't had maps for you
know like three years or like like
realistically because yeah i don't count
bringing a d1 map back but
um i i actually think game modes are
more necessary than than
new maps like
you know i could play javelin all day if
it's like
capture the flag and then oddball and
then like you know an entirely different
game mode because i'm going to play the
map differently so i feel like game
modes are over over maps but anywho's i
just keep thinking about this all in
separate playlists it kills me
they'll introduce a new mode and it's
its own playlist rather than making one
playlist yeah it's just like rotates
yeah you jump in you don't know what
you're going to be doing you just jump
it could be this is the social playlist
it could be
it could be mayhem it could be team
scorched it could be clash it could be
control it could be supremacy it could
be a rift and you don't know until you
start
and i'm like just yeah just add the
voting system if possible if people get
annoyed with the the next thing in the
queue so to speak of the random modes
like imagine imagine if they had like
okay rumble at all times
comp at all times which don't even get
me started on comp they i don't know
they're just you're in the right company
here yeah right company yeah we talk
about this every week every week we feel
like yeah the compositions and just the
middle
playlist was everything else you know
and like yeah and then imagine you could
vote on maps
i don't know oh my god
can you cancel i told you about these
demands you're doing you're very
very demanding yeah you've got you're uh
yeah
you're what we'd like to call a high
maintenance player we've got uh
so demanding for requesting these
features that every other multiplayer
game has yeah
yeah
you want a new game mode we gave you one
like seven years ago you should be fine
yeah but yeah we got we gotta we gotta
hold their feet to the fight if the devs
are listening we love you but we love
you and we need some stuff
the pvp love ain't that fair we know we
gotta speak on it and we're gonna
continue to speak on it yeah you know
but yeah glad castle's here that's that
big speed i have wondered in the past
like
why why doesn't comp succeed you know i
i like try and compare it if there's no
reason to go in there
all right
that's the other one no loot no ranking
with halo you at least you had that
number 50 to chase and there was i
believe like
a restricted number of people that could
truly be at level 50 it was like ever
changing so if you like reach level 50
and then you quit playing
eventually if you logged back in you
would not be level 50 anymore which was
kind of cool you had to like maintain
yourself
you had to maintain it yeah and the
whole point at least that's how it was
in halo 3. i think it was like that in
halo 2 but
the point was like oh if you haven't
played in this amount of time like
you're probably not
properly representing level 50 anymore
like you're probably not as good as you
were yeah a month ago when you last
logged in so like for how long it would
take but yeah like just chasing it and
then maintaining it it's one of those
things that i feel in destiny that
i'm not huge on ranked stuff just
because i've never really gotten into it
in most games i never have but i also
feel like bungie is afraid to label
anybody
they're afraid to put a label on and be
like you are bronze three you got a
whole lot of work to do and i feel like
they're afraid to put that label
on anyone like
you are rank
763 248 in the strike playlist you've
got a long ways to go but i like
i mean if it does feel like they have
these hidden numbers and stuff in the
background and matchmaking has and
hasn't had skill based matchmaking but
as you said comp has no ladder and it's
like they're afraid to label someone
with anything like you say halo's like
bam onyx whatever you can just put a
number on it and you're like if and
glory is this weird up and down and not
weird matchmaking kinda you get some but
you don't lose very much because we
don't want to hurt your feelings that
bad
they're kind of like the participation
medal afraid to hurt your feelings in
pvp situation and it feels like they
just want to give everybody a blue
ribbon if they play long enough and i at
some point they got to get some tough
love to people and be like you're not
that good there are people much better
than you and you've got some work to do
i know i'm not that good i'd go in there
and be like like what are there's five
levels i'd be like
maybe like silver one is probably where
i'd see myself and i eek up into gold
three and be like yes and that's like i
still gotta go through platinum and try
and get to the high one but like that's
something you you feel accomplishment in
those levels too and if they don't give
you a chance to go after that that's why
i'm hoping season 19 the glory playlist
rework stuff
god i hope so i really do
i know i'm asking for stuff again we got
one map i know i got excited
let's be happy with the one little
cracking to us and you all i apologize
i apologize i got i got hopeful i
shouldn't do that
can't can't dream in pvp i'm sorry
running uh running into someone who's
better than you
at least for me has always i've never
been like upset about it it's always
been like humbling and then it kind of
like
drives me to try and be better i'll
never forget like there's a guy named
lunars
who he streams on twitch all the time he
i remember
back this is a while back you youtube
making youtube videos has actually taken
away a lot of my gaming because
i spend way more hours now making the
videos and i do gaming but before i was
like diving really deep into youtube
i you know i was like playing destiny
non-stop and i remember like i ran into
i just played so much rumble over and
over and over and over and i kept you
know improving and it was exciting so i
got back
i ran into this guy named lunars
it was like
he like be he stomped me you know i
could go on like 15 game winning streaks
first place no problem and then i ran
into this guy and like he stomped me
like
six games in a row
i went to his steam
page like dude you're the best player
i've ever freaking i gotta check your
stats are you real
and i found him on twitch
and i went in there and told him how
good he was i was just like oh my god i
didn't know someone could be that much
better and then like
my drive went through the roof because i
was like i
i need to be better and i so i feel like
when you match people who are better
than you at least from my perspective
it's a wake-up call when i'm like holy
crap there is actually
a lot of skill gap here that i'm
i i'm missing out on or like i i need to
improve to try and match so
i don't know yeah
agreed
all right
one more random thing by the way events
because we got so far off topic we were
actually yeah
sorry i don't know that's like that's
part of the podcast is we get off on
tangents and you're a pvp player and
believe me i actually wanted your
thoughts on this oh so stuff so i'm glad
we actually got into that chat because
i didn't exactly know how to get us
there because we've talked about it but
i wanted to guess your thoughts which
was perfect so
you opened up and
thanks
um but events are technically gonna have
like seals and titles to them they're
gonna have like a solstice title and
seal to work for but there's also gonna
be like a year-long
did you do all of the seasonal event
seals so teddy has one more thing two
more things to actually go for now if
he's gonna be a hundred percent
completionist so we wish you the best of
luck teddy now you can't take vacation
around seasonal events either if you
want everything you have to be there
holy cow um also this i didn't want to
get your guys take on the upgraded event
card so you have the event card which is
going to be like here's the things to do
in the event to upgrade shaders ships
and basic stuff that you're going to get
through the event and they said some of
the stuff specifically is going to be
earnable which i did appreciate on the
other side there's an upgraded event
card that will cost you a thousand
silver it will immediately grant players
exotic reward bundle so the one for
example is going to have an emote a
ghost shell and a legendary shader and
then if you earn tickets which seem to
come from like doing the event
challenges you're going to be able to
basically cash in the tickets for other
stuff that are going to be part of the
upgraded card
now these are all cosmetics
do you guys think this is getting to be
another place of micro transaction e do
you feel this is a little greedy to have
like a pay situation for
a seasonal event i gotta get travis
first because he loves the amount of
currencies and the number of times they
charge you for things travis thoughts
yeah
yeah
yeah
you know how uh
whenever these events suck
everyone goes what did you expect it was
a free event
well
now they're not free anymore
right because
usually you get the unlockables by
completing the the triumphs right you
get the emotes done all that stuff and
uh
now it sounds like there's going to be a
paywall to getting access to that to
that triumph list which that's how it
was in d1 it's fine their their model
there was a little bit differently it
worked a little bit differently they
didn't have as many ways to get you they
weren't you know asking you to pay for
transmog and
you know eververse wasn't as
you know universally applied to their
entire sandbox box all that stuff
so i guess it's it's free to play their
seasonal events it's just not free to
get anything from doing that unless you
buy into their little book
um
yeah i
i hate this
it also seemed like maybe there was a
way to kind of pay past the doing the
actual event like you could
did i interpret that wrong but it seemed
like it was like we got it right okay so
let me read it verbatim just so bring it
down make sure we're accurate before we
before we lane
new event means new event-themed
cosmetics for guardians to customize
their experience while those items have
traditionally been part of the store
with the upcoming solstice event we will
curate a collection of those items as
unique rewards through the event card
itself those rewards will only be
available through the event card during
their initial release
but like most of our cosmetics there's
always a chance they'll be available in
the eververse later while the event card
and event challenge rewards are free to
all players acquiring these extra
cosmetics were acquiring these extra
cosmetic rewards will require players to
purchase the upgraded event card
upgrade upgrading the event card will
cost a thousand silver and immediately
grants an exotic bundle and then you can
get more by getting tickets so i feel
like i had an i i had a concept in the
first paragraph and it made it i got
confused in the second paragraph that's
just so bad this is exactly what we were
talking about the beginning like what
does that even mean they're why are they
so bad at explaining things
yeah
i don't know i don't even get that the
first day yeah so i i guess i'm not sure
but just my initial
reading of it when i was going through
the 12 was that like you could basically
pay just like you can pay to level up
your season pass you can pay to not play
the game it sounds like you can also pay
to not do the seasonal
or some of them maybe
make a live service event switch yeah
i'm hoping there's a variety like if you
want
the hot dog eating champ exotic emote
that is going to come separately through
the event card but maybe if you do the
full
challenge maybe you'll get you'll be
able to earn one specifically just by
doing it i'm hoping there's a
distinction that's was like if it's all
if you can pay to pass it
or it's like
and you and there's no difference
between the two that's why i would have
an issue as well because then at that
point you're just like as you said paid
and not play the game
i guess it's a choice but
weird choice to pay to skip playing
destiny because that's up to you
it's all cosmetic most of the time i
don't care but it's just it was weird
their model is more confusing than it's
ever been so i recently had a friend
tell me that he got into which queen and
he bought like the ultra deluxe super
edition of witch queen and then he
booted up the game and they were like
here's the two dlc's you don't have and
here's all the different activities you
can't do and stuff like that because
it's been a couple years since he's
turned on he was just like but i bought
the most expensive version like i don't
really understand it right uh now we're
learning the dungeons are being sold
separately i just feel like
they they're they've got them
so so wrong so so wrong it's like you
either are fortnite where everything's
free and it's very clear that like you
are just paying for cosmetics because
the experience is free or you're a
walled garden where you pay to get into
the game and then they don't bother you
with this sort of stuff but the fact
that they're doing both and then when
you get in they're bothering you in so
many different ways it's like now buy
this event card and you know if you want
to transmog things buy that and also ev
anytime you want to do an emote buy that
and shaders and it's just like
it's not as bad as like raid shadow
legends whenever you get back to your
home screen try this pack it's not quite
that but as you were describing it it's
like
isn't that a full free-to-play game
though yeah i've i've never paid for
anything on raid shadow legends then
i've put you know off and on a decent
amount hours into it but yeah it's
totally free
it's worse than raid shadow legends
because
remember this when you guys are looking
at those ads it's not so bad yeah
at least at least that game knows what
it is it's like you're not going to pay
to play the game but
we're going to get you as best we can
gentian impact another great game which
i actually think is similar in quality
to destiny
does it very well which is like you're
never going to pay for anything but
we're going to super monetize you with
those collectible characters and that
sort of stuff and it's like okay i can
accept that because i didn't pay for
this game but nobody wants to pay like
80 to play the witch queen and then find
out that they don't have all of the
expansions and then find out that
they're going to get charged nickel and
dimed every time an event happens and
it's just it's ridiculous at this point
i mean
i mean
um sorry i totally jumped in there no no
um
like
being able to just buy every everything
like everything so like you said like he
bought the most expensive version he
could
he logs into the game and the first
thing they say is by the way you don't
get to play this and this i mean
i know what you're asking in my opinion
is that when which queen comes out that
old stuff should be free
you don't need to go buy others no one
should be buying shadow keep i'm sorry
that should not have a price
and then you should have bought shadow
keep when it came out i mean that's
going to be painful because would you
give that one a six was that a six yeah
i think so yeah
but i mean that's like the but as you
just said that like hey what are you how
do you
sorry i'll eventually get my sentence
out bungie is trying to build a player
base because eventually it just slowly
withers away if you don't get new people
in but as you guys have said if you make
it so complicated to get into the game
if you buy the deluxe edition of witch
queen
everything else should just be in there
too that should be 80 you should catch
up and get the old stuff because it is
three years old at this point there's no
reason you should have to
do all of this and
we'll get to the dungeon here in a
second but
that's not great either yeah they want
you to buy the package because if you
don't you have been nickeled and dimed
to death at this point
and i used to wonder like are they
afraid that the community will be like
i had to pay you know like over the past
five years i had to pay you know
40 then 80 then 60 then 40. whatever it
is and the person who bought these are
they just got it people are going to be
like i had to pay 600 or whatever it is
maybe it's like 300 over the last five
years why are you selling all of this
stuff to to this new person for you know
a hundred dollars but part of me is like
that's how life works
you got five years of entertainment for
it you go to go see a movie you spend
fifty dollars for two hours of
entertainment like
i yeah i don't know it blows my mind so
i just feel like whenever people buy a
brent like the new expansion like witch
queen like like your friend travis
it should just get
everything that is available yeah right
right then and there yeah
it's super frustrating to spend eighty
dollars and get in the game and then
immediately be like wow
i thought that was it but it's just the
beginning and what a way to get a what a
way to like convert to a refund you know
like yeah sure steam refund slap your
customer in the face i was tweeting at
bungie by the way i saw him on twitter
today he was tweeting at bungie like yo
explain to me what i'm supposed to buy i
don't i don't get why i can't play this
and this and i was just like yo that's
such a bad look like
come on man
so yeah
i just think this is and you know what
worries me too is that now that they're
acquired by sony you know that they're
going to be the experts on how sony does
all of their games as a service and i
think while they're well they've
absolutely nailed the quality problem
and the uh content pipeline and all the
stuff that destiny's good at and the
reason they play it one thing that
they're just terrible at is the
monetization thing and making clear what
you're buying and sony's also not good
at that so i'm really worried
is not a good
example actually super worried about the
games as a service game like
monetization model for sony games in the
future i'm like dude if they follow
bungie as an example like oh you did a
super successful game this must be the
industry standard i'm gonna be like yo
dude no
do not do that yeah i was like i was
like i want to look at the books i want
to sit down with the cfo and be like
okay so i got to understand
like what how does all this work do you
guys really it's like in my mind that's
the point like we see bungie try and
do very good things
for community for social activities
making political stances and all these
things and then you turn around and see
them do like scummy things on a business
practice and it's scummy's like not a
great word to describe but when when it
was like they were selling forsaken all
the way up until that pack came out and
then they turned around and had the
forsaken pack or key or
whatever you would buy the dungeon and
the raid basically at that point i'm
going
that did not feel good as a consumer to
know that that existed and if anybody
bought that i'm like i'm sorry
and like i've got to understand as they
want to do really good things i gotta
understand the business side sometimes
because at some point yeah somebody said
it's greasy and it's scummy and it is to
a point at some point as you guys have
said you're gonna burn enough people
you're never gonna get people back in
and if somebody gets burned by destiny
and they release this new pvp ip
how's somebody gonna think hey bungee
screwed me before what's the
monetization gonna be like here is it
gonna be good bad trash who knows
so it's like they they need to be
looking at more of a long-term solution
sorry i feel like i've been talking
about this podcast my fault um no you're
so good man it's your show also i feel
like um
i feel like it's can it's even worse
with the content vault
this model is even worse in the way that
they're charging people when they're
taking stuff away
how if they're selling i can't get
married
maddie wants to play yeah i'm sorry for
sure
why would he play right if like
that i have the same problem with hogue
where i'm like it's a good game which
queen's really good i gave it an 8 out
of 10. like you should play it and he's
like
you know what am i gonna i'm gonna buy
it this year and then two years they're
gonna put in the vault and i'm like fair
point i mean yeah and he ended up buying
it but only because his brother like
worked on the game or whatever yeah yeah
yeah
situation but uh yeah i just think it's
um
with the content vault is murky your
business models murky the fact that
you're selling expansions and now you're
selling season passes and now you're
selling event passes and now you're
selling micro transactions up the wazoo
it's like dude
this is not good no this isn't brutal my
brother is i'm gonna go visit him here
this weekend um
he just went to final fantasy 14.
he got to play
yeah everything
and then now he's up with shadowbringers
and he loves it and i know he puts a ton
of time in but he literally got to
experience the entire game it could be a
lot of hours to get there but everything
was there and that's one of those
whereas you said the content vault hurts
because nobody can experience the cade
moment i talked about
it's gone new players
you can watch the trailer e that's how
the rest of us experience it
ouch sorry yeah ouch
yeah look you know i don't got much to
add you guys pretty much knocked it out
the park it they've been getting away
with a multiple
multiple monetization models that no
other game is usually afforded and it's
because one i think we love it this fan
base is for the most part been extremely
consistent and number two let's be
honest as much as i'm a hardcore destiny
fan
you know
they they have survived pretty much all
they their competition
so they haven't been pushed again and
you know division had this little moment
anthem thought it was going to do
something something there's nothing
that's truly pushed them where they have
been in that where i feel where it was
like what is it the house of wolves days
they had a content drop i believe
division one came out the time was
pretty strong it took a lot of their
player base away so you had that going
on and then the last point i say is just
that
look i'm a veteran player
and i'm confused by this
like i like i get confused by like that
you have to
the castle's shadowed technically though
this wouldn't have to exist because we
have to shadows have to explain what's
going on
same thing like there's so many youtube
channels that are like
there are stats for guns that are not in
the game and there are youtubers that go
out castle fallouts shadow last week all
of so many pvp players explain things
that are not apparent in the game how
does an accuracy code work stats that
are hidden in the api and all of a
sudden you're like i have to go to
youtube to understand how to play your
game
yeah it's just very strange and and yeah
they credit they've been able to get
away with this consistently and there's
just been no things so like i said
that's why i always say competition is
good and you do want them pushed because
at the end of the day you know look
this is stuff i i don't even know what's
going on here man like like i'm just
gonna log in i'm gonna e i'm gonna turn
on your video you're gonna explain it
and then i'll be like alright this is
what i'm supposed to do okay cool and
that's it all right like i don't even
know anymore like i'm like okay what
what are we doing no
and if i don't know
what do you think the new player
experiences like he's like what i spent
80 and i don't get what and i do this
and yeah i mean at this point give me a
subscription model keep the get rid of
the content vault make the it'll make
the all the ever stuff earnable and i
will do a subscription model right now
and i'll get shot by the entire
community for saying that but
if it was just simplified
somewhere me feels that would be better
if they were able to actually like
here's our guaranteed revenue for the
subscriptions we've got or something
stupid like that it'd be i know it's not
ever gonna happen i get that but it's
just like
simplifying
so much of this would help go ahead for
whatever reason they're just so bad at
explaining everything and it blows my
mind like black wigs got a good point he
said he thinks the simple fact that
they've outlived all the competition
means that they are the new norm yeah
but they are the norm and the neuron
said just the other day i saw a post
where a new player was so confused about
where to start that's true yeah you new
play new light players have it awful
right now they really do yeah
yeah and then like there's so i guess
you know destiny being the game that it
is that you you must sink a ton of hours
just to even get to a point where you
can compete whether it's pvp or i guess
higher end pve like
the fact that that's you know that's the
game it is what it is but it that also
it shuts the door on so many people like
my brother
he's the kind of guy who you know
stereotype like he's got kids he just
wants to in the evening hop on
get a couple matches in but like destiny
i just can't get him to i just can't get
him to play it he's like dude
i can just hop on to apex and i can just
like like
within five seconds
i'm able to go in and enjoy the game and
like
compete against other players or
whatever and and um
you know fortnite's the same way there's
just so many games where you can just
hop in and immediately be at at at a
good level which
god it's just yeah he's gonna say like
people like my brother
yeah like uh the to the comment that
said like bungie's the norm they've
outlived all their competitors so they
get to kind of make the rules
um i think that was true at a time i
think it's increasingly not true i think
that
games as a service you know with
successes like fortnite and apex and
those are all pvp games so bungie's you
know destiny is one of the only pvp like
focused games that's still doing it uh
and at the scale they're doing it but i
think increasingly that it's just not
true and it's not going to cut the
mustard and
bungie is only going to be appealing to
its existing player base with the way
they currently have things modeled
they're not really doing anything to win
new players
that's going to be the big problem going
forward is that they have to like clean
up their model make it clear i thought
they were going free to play it seems
like they're going the exact opposite
they kind of told us they were going to
free to play a couple years ago i feel
like and then it kind of turned around
and they were like nah not anymore so um
i i i feel like they this is something
they're gonna have to address
soon because there's a lot of games as a
service success stories out there and
none of them are even close to destiny
in terms of how how bad it feels in
terms of the monetization so
yeah
um i mean that's you guys basically have
covered everything at this point um
and that's just the weird point we're at
it's like we know seasonal events are
coming but now there's another way to
charge people for it
i just said i was like i'll have to see
it when i see it but it's just it's it's
weird i got my little red flag pops up
and i'm wondering
the dog ears the radar like all right
what's gonna be wrong with this one
yeah
yeah it's just a little odd got a couple
patch notes coming um
the consistency of like your plat your
roster updating for different platforms
being faster thank god because i've been
sitting there waiting for like new rad
and black wings be like where you guys
at and they're like i'm here
oh i was like well i don't see you
they're like well we're online and i'm
like two minutes later there it is i'm
like finally
that's true power level's going up by 10
so that's surprising absolutely no one
cause they're just sticking with that
for now uh vault space
uh oh we get a hundred spaces in the
vault now while we know this doesn't
enable players to save every single
piece of loot in the game i'm fully
where i'm a hoarder i have a problem and
i admit it i get it that's fine uh the
team was able to pull some strings and
get a little more space for your vaults
as they continue to investigate future
solutions
this is one of those times where i want
them to come out with a dev diary and
explain why
why what is this weird thing like okay
500 we got to 600 is it like
i want to understand the technical
pieces to this yeah i'm going to be 601
of 600 just give it time it's fine um
but i want to understand the technical
reasons why it's like is the ps4 still
screwing you over is it going to take
too long if there's 600 in here and you
have a certain loading time that you
have to do i don't know what it is
but i want to know
and if they're like hey whenever we get
rid of those old consoles we'll give it
to you but for now we just i don't know
it's just weird yeah it's got to be some
weird like server techn technical yeah
that's like i don't know yeah
uh zur will no longer be able to be
hostage uh held on tuesdays at reset so
he will be able to leave
as he chooses um
scorn snipers no longer going to be
quite as lethal that's good
and then we do have a date on the new
dungeon
shockingly
so the new dungeon is coming in hot it's
going to come in on friday
27th
so you get three days and the dungeon
wow is gonna be here now the dungeon is
1550 for normal difficulty so if you've
played it all now you are good to jump
into normal i have no idea what master
difficulty is going to be like 1590 1600
god only knows
um they did say the loot in there is
going to be one legendary set of armor
per class artifice versions will be
available via master difficulty
that still needs to be in the master
raid but yes it's that seems to be like
a dungeon thing but master raid means
artifice as well like it's good cool
cool like that's the thing uh four new
legendary weapons
two legendary reprised weapons which
makes me wonder
why a brand new dungeon has old weapons
i don't know just to give it more
options with perks we'll see because
it's an old dungeon
they're bringing crota's end into yo
no it's gonna be uh it's gonna be
crazy it's gonna be a dungeon on the
leviathan and you're getting midnight
coup with random rolls
that's that's what it is so
let's go uh you got you do have an
exotic weapon catalyst kind of similar
the way you had gala horn in the
catalyst from whatever experience you
had so of course you guys know guides
will be coming exotic accessory sparrow
or ship so that's going to be a thing
couple emblems i'm sure one's from doing
it flawless one's for finishing basic
stuff um but they're not telling us
anything they're like here's the date
for your dungeon get ready but no story
no theme no enemies no race no zero i've
this is still kind of crazy i love the e
you love this stuff i'm honestly gonna
be like tuesday morning i'm gonna be
streaming at like 6 a.m be like all
right i'm just going to stare at the
screen until we get it
and we're going okay now i'm going to
make my little video upload it and log
in like it's going to be a long day but
it'll be a fun one so we'll see
they gave you everything you wanted hey
now we're just going to see how it pays
off
if they can deliver yeah i'll be waiting
for milan and biff to break it down
right now milan and biff are just like
waiting on blocks for the gun to go off
so they can start working again because
right now there's like i need the law
last week of trials is coming up we have
zone capture that one's coming this
weekend so if you want to get any trials
loot
turn in any trials in grams i have like
10 of those to pick up
um
all engrams that all vendors pick them
up because everything resets back to
reputation zero at the new season right
what question no free no no freelance no
freelance freelance is there too so
freelance and zone capture so you got
zone capture and freelance zone capture
zone capture is weird
but you know
it's one of those things
um i've seen zone capture be like bubble
on bubble and it's just this like
overlapping double bubble and then it's
all of a sudden you got like two
so yeah it's like a very old gum
commercial if you guys are old enough to
know that one
[Laughter]
uh you've got a fusion rifle and a
sidearm shown in the picture but more
interestingly we have new armor and i
gotta be honest
i like the titan i like the warlock
the hunter is a damn monkey and it's
like it's
on twitter too i'm not alone but i was
like it it looks like a monkey so i
wanted to get you guys do you guys like
the armor first off
i can dig it i could get jiggy with it a
little gaudy
trials always is it's like very yeah it
always is yeah i don't know how i feel
about the helmets
mm-hmm oh the titan right like a ram
like a ram helmet right
it's like a it's like the ram horns are
like tucked i don't know i'm like i like
how it's like melded in and tucked into
it i like it a little more than like
here's my horns way out here like i'm
tired of like spaceship helms so the
fact that it's like all in there i'm i'm
more for that i'll take it right yeah i
i agree with that yeah but yeah
delegation we we liking it um very
bird-like you know i'm feeling very top
tree energy oh yeah one blade energy
with this i'm you know i might have
wings of sacred dawn on the background
it looks like you're wearing it i've
already got my flow because like one
thing about warlock you gotta you gotta
look good to play good so you know i'm
all about that's why you guys took three
years to win guardian games took you too
long to pick an outfit
[Laughter]
you're like this isn't quite the right
drip three years later i got my outfit
i'm ready okay but i i'm liking by
ceremony i'm feeling very are moon rock
redefines the shotgun ape meta though i
will
shotgun even the monkeys are out here
the hunters i like the undertone though
for the moon moon night if anybody watch
moon night every all the under wrappings
look exactly like moon night i love that
i'm gonna feel in my egyptian robe i'm
feeling egyptian cotton with the papyrus
free i'm ready i'm ready let's go i know
we don't have a hunter on the podcast
but does anybody else have an issue with
the hunter's cloak basically having a
tail
oh yeah people yeah a little strange
it literally hasn't go
hanging down there
i go from this town monkey hunter though
i don't
the head is for sure the worst part the
helmet i just say make that your exotic
and then run around with the monkey tail
it's kind of cool you look like goku
yeah i don't mind oh my god you're right
and they look kind of like they've been
lifted this year i gotta buy the hunter
you know me
got the little friendly um i'm about it
i will be curious to see that one runner
down in action but i was very i i
couldn't do anything but see monkey so
it was yeah oh i need that warlock bar
no that assyrian oh i'll eat that
so the ghost looks cool now the sparrow
[ __ ] are you gonna get this sparrow not
bad
it's not bad that is
that's a nice sparrow yeah this is i'm
going into the pyramids deep with this
this is all me right here yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is the spanx right here let's
go
and the feathers on it yeah and
everything oh this is speaking very
exciting yeah now i was crazy i like the
other one the older one but i've never
got a chance to get it i haven't ever
had one are they gonna phase it out i
don't know i don't know if they'll give
you a chance to get both or if this will
just be the new one it might just be it
might be this is fine
yeah
right that new sparrow is fine i'm all
about it
yeah i saw that one and i was like yeah
that one that's one of the better
looking sparrows
i've seen in quite a while uh yeah it
looks like it's gonna wake up and squawk
at you yes yes yes yes yes
that's the animal right there let's go
and that's basically it um the patch is
gonna be
15 minutes of downtime for a season like
probably one of the shortest so whatever
back end work they've been doing they
were doing background maintenance all
week long
whatever work they've been doing on the
systems very minimal downtime to launch
a brand new season that's impressive
also means much less time for you to not
pre-download a patch and of data miners
ruin stuff which is good so i appreciate
that true it's because all of the new
season that's coming out on tuesday is a
two-minute trailer
oh we're getting it down to the
cinematic and that's it why it's so
little down time it's a two minute
trailer for the dungeon that they want
you to buy on friday i'm done so
yeah oh i did actually i i did skip that
i'm sorry
so the best way to get the dungeon
as well as the one in coming in season
19 is to have the digital deluxe edition
of the witch queen
if you have that you're good to go if
you want to experience the entire year
of destiny 2 content and haven't
purchased the deluxe edition yet on
tuesday that will be 25 off for some
time period so i think that's the whole
which queen 80 thing will probably be
60.
i don't know about like the deluxe
upgrade hopefully that one for that too
if you just want the dungeons it's
totally fine
you will buy them for the witch queen
dungeon key for 2 000 silver which is 20
bucks for two dungeons that'll get you
the dungeon now and the dungeon season
19.
so if for some reason you
have been piecemealing destiny the witch
queen you're definitely gonna be paying
for it
right
yeah
yeah this is one of those things when
they're like oh the dungeons are gonna
be they basically like get the package
don't don't do anything else is what
they're saying we'll give you an option
but it's a horrible option this doesn't
affect everyone anyone here listening to
this show or a guest here or whatever
but it it's gonna affect the people that
already have the worst destiny
experience out of all of us right
that's i got the free copy of this
dungeon well you have to get the season
or the deluxe edition or this that or
the other bubble and philadelphia
yeah it's a polite stick up that's all
it's just a polite sticker you know a
polite
guy can just get in there you know just
get in there get the damn deluxe did the
one that we want yeah
you can play with me
come on just just give me the 80 bucks
that's no big deal you know just a
problem just a friendly robbery is
nothing i'm sorry
it is very it's
we heard about it before we kind of i
don't know what we were expecting it to
be i don't know if we said maybe like
five bucks for a dungeon how much is a
piece of content but it's like it's one
note on the director's 20 is 10 bucks
that's like i mean
you know the the dungeons are longer you
know if i go so power level increase per
week
i mean think of the you can buy 10 power
levels when you start the season that is
true i forgot about that it's free real
estate
yeah powerful drop
we already we already hash through all
the pricing and everything but i forgot
to bring it up and i was just like
i guess i'm not too surprised but
yeah if you're if you want to play
destiny just get the deluxe and just get
or don't
it's up to you but if you want to play
destiny deluxe is like the only way to
do it it feels like anymore it's not
it's not worth it any other way it seems
like
shout out to the new lights
i know right yeah shout out to the new
lights and also the about to be not
lights
no way they're sticking around this game
with
oh my goodness
yeah you're going to have to get a joe's
yeah to a new player to get them in
you're going to have to like gift them
the entire witch queen edition or
something
that's what i used to have to do to
people oh so now i i just realized what
the uh
it's
it's just gifted subscriptions to
destiny that's all it is
the pyramids are filled with all the
upset guardians who
left the game
and now comment dead game in all of the
destiny comment sections that's what's
on the pyramid ship it's
just a bunch of disgruntled guardians
that's the nightmares floating around
the moon well i thought the period the
pyramids were uh a lore reason to to to
enter the the content vault to create a
katya phone so they can disappear the
cat
yeah they give it as a thematic reason
we have a reason to take away your
content and then not give it back to you
maybe ever we'll see it's a pyramid
scheme hey
yo nice that was black wings i took that
from heaven
that was nice do you think there's any
destiny fan who
bought forsaken and then like a week
before it came out like some accident
happened and they ended up in a coma for
like three years and then they woke up
and and forsaken was content vaulted
i think there's even one person probably
statistically probably not probably not
that's that's a very very small
set of that's a very small cross-section
of because if there's even one person
that dude
deserves like he should sue someone that
guy
dude
damn refund damn it he deserves it
well
yeah uh we get a new season on tuesday
we don't have a damn clue what it's
about so
tune in tuesday morning i'll be live um
i know travis is probably going to be
covering it in some way a little bit
maybe you'll have an article but i
assume you will
and we're going to see we're going to
hit the round basically running with new
stuff now some things to think about
possibly new craftable weapons
so we get something related to the
season god i hope so maybe some older
craftable weapons getting patterns we'll
have to see where those maybe come from
are we going to be able to craft
i don't know
yeah there's so much we don't know i i'm
very curious what had if it's a vidoc if
it's a trailer if it's just you're
getting solo 3.0 here's the story go
i don't know what else
yeah so castle can i
no sorry real quick can i because i
didn't get to comment on this earlier
because we just skipped over it but can
i just say that 100 more vault spaces
won't make you happier it's a band-aid
on a solution that is a band-aid on a
problem that's completely broken you
need to marine condo your life to start
deleting stuff y'all are savages that's
what i have to say to the destiny
community right now
it's it's true we brushed over it very
quickly we did go over here i think the
100 extra vault spaces again is going to
do nothing
stupid it's a stupid system i hope that
they
destroy all the vault space hope you
can't keep anything that's not on your
character that's what i hope happens to
all you people blow up the tower again
blow up the tower
a friend of mine his name is yarda he
made a video about it oh i know that guy
i actually did the day one um uh raid
with him uh
oh really uh yeah i i was on his day one
g j e r
d a whatever yeah yeah that guy here he
would it what was the uh what was the
the ice planet raid uh stone deep stone
grip deep still grip yeah yeah yeah yeah
we did a 24 hour completion together
well that's cool yeah he
wonderful guy fantastic um really good
friends with him
he made a video about just deleting his
entire vault he deleted all 500
everything i think i saw yeah somebody
at my discord beautiful pointed me very
directly at that video yeah
make sure you looked at it yeah they
like maybe you should do this right here
yeah
he's very um it's very unique like it's
it's like a three hour you know it's not
like a 10 12 minute thing but it just
goes into like
you know bringing it back to basics with
gaming and like
how many of those things you really use
and anyways i i feel like his video
is a perfect
um
not like example but like
the extra hundred vault spaces i feel
like
are gonna be so meaningless like
everyone's gonna be pumped about having
extra vault space but like you said
montes like you're gonna you're gonna
reach that maximum in
four days
you're not the same issue
500 doesn't make you happy 600 i'm gonna
make a damn big difference i know i get
it but yeah i will say also when they do
stupid stuff and everybody's like hey
clean out your fault get rid of all
those old things iron banner light level
doesn't matter anymore like when they
pull random crap like that and somebody
like a pvp player like castle or fallout
are like hey all those things that we
wanted you to delete now you can go into
iron banner with your spare rations you
can go in there with your revoker and
they're all going to work
like can you imagine a revoker coming
back in iron banner
no i hear you yeah
bear ashens
uh i don't know what else is going to be
awful but i mean those type of things
that people hold on to now grant and
some of those you can pull from
collections but like a spare rations
some might somebody might have a god
roll on that one
you should have been like hey at sunset
i probably will never delete it again
well
now you could use it and then there's
the idea should you just free yourself
and not care anymore and deal and be
fine but then bungie does do this here's
the decision
yeah i technically still have a blast
furnace in my vault
oh you still got it i have one i have i
actually have a go figure that i'll be
able to pull out for iron banner i will
have to do that at some point for
entertainment value because i kept going
are you really going to jump in a
crucible at 220 light and iron banners
everything's 13.50
i'm just saying like that's there are
there are many things that i should
delete from my vault i'm like horrible
just like making decisions just delete
some stuff that's fine but
like there are like four or five
nostalgic weapons i keep i don't even
have that many nostalgia ones but like
my go figure theoretically now i'm like
oh
i can actually go use that
and it's basically a follow-up question
anybody
of course that's why we're here to roast
me is there is there a room in your
house that's just cardboard boxes
no
you sure yes
you know what i don't believe you but i
accept the answer that'll be cool
there's not a room in my house that's
cardboard boxes we don't have that much
storage space which is probably a
godsend for me so it's fine true yeah
same with us yeah we don't have them
constantly uh are you constantly
tweeting at your city to provide you
more vault space
[Music]
i'm gonna need to get a storage unit uh
i need to upgrade my storage unit it's
got to get bigger and bigger and bigger
yeah nuts
and just like in destiny your storage
unit is 100 filled with the guns
because you're a texan oh yeah no
[Laughter]
is there anything else that's floating
through your mind with regards to next
season anything else that you have like
their hopes wants solar 3.0
any big anything that you've got like i
hope to see this or
please god i hope i don't see this
man i just want
more
game modes in pvp oh there you go girl
get ready to cry on tuesday
i'm worried stupid idiot
wow our podcast is
is
that still have hope it really hurts me
i'm like i need to just i need to just
smother you right now
you're not suffering yeah
it's like i'm in uh shark tank or
dragon's den and you're kevin o'leary
being like it's time to bury this idea
and move on with your life
i'm worried i'm so i'm actually worried
so you know stasis with fragments and
aspects brought in a lot more ability
play
voi if sure eventually they toned it
back void brought in a lot more
a bit you know we got child of the old
god we got these
damn void buddies
on all the warlocks we've got titans
with those
everybody everywhere
i'm kind of worried that like okay
we had stasis
and then like void added another layer
and now it's like god is solar going to
be the same thing it's just more
powerful
yes it's coming because they want to
make people make sure people buy these
deluxe editions
yeah so i'm a little worried that like
and then eventually they'll add arc and
then maybe once all of them have
fragments and aspects maybe they'll be
like okay let's
season
we know how this show goes this thing
will come in hot as hell literally for
so long and then we're gonna be oh man
in a trailer titan's gonna be blowing up
everything warlock's gonna have some
fire buddy doing something
hunters will dodge or do something
whatever hunters do
and it's just gonna be super broken for
that first season and then
tone it back the next season it's it's
the routine but yeah i i definitely i've
come to learn that i just have to
embrace it i just have to go full send
into whatever it is that is cheesy or
annoying or whatever and just be like
yeah just fully become part of the
problem just roll with the meta you know
just
go for it like i wasn't that into
fusions
um for quite a while until i saw that
video recently and holy man oh you got
that suspect popping bro i seen it i was
like oh yeah that's insane
it's fine i just finally said yeah i'm
going for it so anyways no but i mean
new content in in general always always
nice um we'll see what see what they
bring us no doubt
what are your your high hopes and fears
for
tuesday high hopes always story story
first for me
because you know i'm past the cancer
stage the people i
just get your map and shut up get in the
corner and be happy but um
for me yeah it's just i i want to know
the player you know like how we got myth
racks okay okay what's going on it's
falling and doing whatever i just want
to know what the player is and where
that's gonna go
and then yeah i just wanna i wanna dive
into the fragments of solar i wanna do
the synergies i wanna i've got builds in
my head already you know that i want to
mess around
yeah thank you for that he shout get a
big shout out to mommy the only thing
that was killing my void 3.0 was i never
had the bountiful wells mod and i don't
know how i missed it because i played
season of the lost damn near every week
and for whatever reason that was the
only one i had so now you know embracing
the well build i want to see where they
go with that i want to know if they
they're very heavy in the wells right
now but i want to know if
they're going to bring back um
any orb stuff like um you know like
charged with light stuff if anything
happens or something new which i'd be
surprised
and last thing for me is always the
artifact the artifact what are they
going to induce us how to play what's
the new how are they going to nudge us
into using nudge it's a
very violent shove
yes yes yes and you know which is going
to be i always just like what's his
anti-barrier that's one of my favorite
what's the end time
overload dear god after this tell me
what overload is because oh bro auto
rifle smg overload please never again
all right you're gonna be on all side
arms
for you guys
you tighten this you gotta do that me i
just throw the pan boots and throw a
rift out yeah what the hell
warlocks are supposed to be the studious
ones and they can't even pronounce their
own exotics
[Laughter]
very very studious there might want to
take those glasses off you're not living
up to them yeah but now let's say i just
want to i just want to get get deep
within i'm excited for the season i am i
i think we have potential i don't want
to get too crazy i think we have a
potential to be a solid season dungeon
3.0 something and a secret lore be
good foundation for a solid season in my
opinion
travis
uh
i don't know they haven't shown me
anything
we'll see i mean i i i'll play it i'll
be there on tuesday i'll play right
along with you guys and then you can
find me here next thursday probably
complaining about some new set of things
what travis is complaining again that's
not a normal podcast
e not each not travis jarvis is so
agreeable with everything travis is so
positive he's a ray of sunshine on every
podcast have you seen him on bitcast he
is just glowing on there there are no
arguments between him and an attorney
they get along it's like magic and
rainbows coming out of their butts
that's amazing 10 minutes earlier in the
podcast you stupid idiot
early we get canceled early
castle's like i'm never coming back to
this podcast he's like what podcast did
i enjoy oh man i was doing it i was
doing so good and then they threw me
under the bus i mentioned was golden eye
and i got destroyed yeah yeah golden
knights got destroyed pvp hopes got shot
in the face
all of a sudden his love for like under
the bus i was driving the bus
yeah i was and then after you rolled
over him you put it in reverse and had
to get another message
gotta get that double set of tracks uh
for me it's the dungeon i mean story i'm
with you 100 i want to know the story
um
because if the story ties to the dungeon
that's an exciting week
but yeah i want to see the dungeon
because i know grasp of everest was
cool in moments and had some uniqueness
to it but that middle section when you
repeat it with the like dunking the
balls and those pieces as well yeah that
one
it got a it got a little
like prophecy still sets the bar really
high like yeah prophecies prophecy is
just really good um i also like the idea
of if they get into more bosses that
move as opposed to standing still
um stuff like that will be cool and that
was like prophecy had a boss that did
like you had to go chase him it was
actually unique so again
so i mean i'm hoping the dungeon can
kind of set a new bar because we've had
you know a ranking now and i'm hoping
this i'd love to see like this be the
top dungeon for multiple reasons great
loot great you know experience maybe
cool story because this last one was
about pirates like i want to know the
dungeon that's my big one um
craftables will be the other one i'll be
curious what craftable weapons we get
please
i hope there's a solar bow in there
just so i can finally stop telling
people the only solar boat that you can
go gets in a raid
yeah yeah
using tikku all the time for everything
yeah
but yeah that's basically it um
next week is going to be a whole
different episode and it is actually
just going to be the three of us um so
no guests next week so just three of us
giving our raw feedback a couple days
later than jumping straight into the
dungeon the next day and now i don't
have to hold back no
yeah now he doesn't know just in case
you're wondering this is tame travis
this is dave yeah
we're about to get
he's behaving baby only reason he won't
go to a 10 is because he actually has a
spouse that may hear words that come out
of his mouth yeah they don't want to get
cancelled that's why i don't know
he can't get canceled he's gonna he's
gonna flirt with that line though
for sure and then 200 i'm working on
something still trying to see if it'll
come together so we will have to see
there but um yeah that could be an
exciting one and then after that we have
gcx so a couple exciting weeks coming up
looking forward to gcx looking forward
to buying uh buying these gentlemen a
beverage hanging out grab a meal give
them a hug actually meet them in person
so should be a good time
i i bet you by buying a beverage he
means he's gonna
make us pay for
some advanced gg using his code so
that's what he is
advanced gg
real quick and then you're out because
that's right let's go let's get this
money holy man or give me a
top couple if you can't decide
you just made the podcast go on for
another two hours
do they sell the triple wreck triple
berry or whatever anymore i feel like
they don't it's there maybe they do it's
always sold out
that one was always one of my favorites
um
mango splash from emptash that one's
good
you know what ass to cross
the nasty whatever that's the mysterious
marketing i feel like so many people
don't buy it because yeah yeah it's just
like
but man it's good
yeah i'm gonna have to get that travis
some of that new
hydration sauce that's right
right yeah
earth sauce
it's back mm-hmm hashtag
beverage
clueless earth sauce so if you listen to
this and you want to tag us for this
pause podcast hashtag clueless earth
sauce because this is a mess of an
episode and well hashtag earth sauce
take the oath that's mine
back for daddy
dj
you actually are gonna have to meet him
i've been do you gotta tell this yeah
it's a battle there's a battle going on
yeah there's a battle going on so i
don't know how this
stupid subject came up and then i didn't
even know what was gonna happen all of a
sudden i'm like i'm in a battle and i'm
like what has happened he's in a fitness
battle with with dj so i told he i was
like yo eat kickboxing not fitness i'm
not in the best shape right now well not
but just like
aesthetic right so he's like i've kicked
him he's like he kickboxed before so he
was like really he was like well i play
hockey and you know i've got the best
cat i'm like bro like you i'm i want to
be nice
it's you're not competing so this man is
literally training
rollerblade he's like evangelist is not
ready for what's about to happen
oh my god
training he's trying to get he's trying
to get his richardson's ready apparently
he's gonna compete in cavs and i'm like
there's a calf off
[Laughter]
so you have to judge this apparently
because
we have to be able to judge yeah then
i'm just not going to meet ibontis
either this is an easy equation for me
yeah you gotta come for the calf off man
that's what it is
you think i'm a good judge for judging
cavs really do i look like the best
judge for that
yeah he might kill us all that's fine
that's why i'm glad he's not there
it's fine
no like
i've never claimed to have like i've
never claimed
i have decent calves like just and i've
been told that and i'm like that's fine
it was like that's just genetics because
shoulders are one of those things for me
like i would work on forever and may not
get there and cog's got shoulders so
it's like yet another flex right until
the end of the show we just have
something hey flex hey i complimented
cog on his shoulders over here my
flowers do my flowers i'm carrying extra
weight right now i'm just going to tell
everybody that so it's like i'm not i'm
not where i want to be but it's in my
pants
that's a real muscle all right we're
going left we're getting demonetized
okay um yeah before we lose everyone uh
castle thank you for being here an
absolute pleasure having you on but
before you go again remind everybody
where to find you if you got any videos
in the oven right now stuff to look
forward to floor is yours
okay well first of all thanks for having
me uh super fun this was like this i
don't know this flew by
did not feel like two hours for me um so
yeah love to come back uh you know
someday in the future and
thanks again for having me um
excited for the new season i'm working
my next video gosh
i'm slightly nervous so most of my
videos are usually like
explanations or guides or like breaking
down a weapon or whatever i'm trying my
first ever like fully entertainment
style video and it's called the life of
a titan
i'm trying to release how many crayons
are in this video i gotta know so so
no crayons okay try to to not use the
crayon meme okay and there you go
anyways he's going high brown still
working on it okay yeah
a little nervous because we'll see how
it does entertainment stuff
entertainment like pure entertainment
style is something i haven't tried
before so i've done one of those and i
was about yeah i was like
i was a little nervous so yeah we'll do
fine
so
but uh
yeah i gotta release it this weekend so
it has a little bit of time before the
new season comes out so we'll see
so go subscribe to this man find him
everywhere twitch twitter youtube
instagram i don't know go find his
linkedin profile hopefully not because
that's too much stalking but kathleen
member of the trials team
[Laughter]
thanks again you guys honestly that was
a blast absolutely no doubt salute to
you man fantastic work love the content
uh also i forgot to shout out uh i love
that hand cannon tier thing that you
that you guys did that was pretty
awesome love seeing that type of level
of complexity and work with the content
salute to castle
no doubt thank you sir you already know
chad man what's going on
yeah i kind of already pitched all my
stuff i got a review that apparently is
out which i found out while i was on the
show
and tweeted about um
yeah i've got some more content coming
out in the next couple days and weeks at
ign.com you can follow me on twitter if
you
want to practice in social media
nihilism to be in your timeline um
you can uh
join me every sunday on bitcast at 8 a.m
uh where i uh hang out with industry
veteran a lawyer
and a man who looks like that in between
state on the front of an anamorphs book
between whether a human and an animal
that little middle one he looks just
like that um
yeah other than that uh thanks for being
on thanks for watching everyone and uh
buy powder from these shills and
subscribe
[Laughter]
duke support recently it's been really
cool to see you know people engaged me
and maddie with our foolishness and food
battles miles
or whatever his name is sounds like his
last name is a dance move
yes
go check that out you know sunday should
be fun with the lords back with the
homies so that'll be good and counting
down i can't believe we're getting close
to gcx but i get to see you fools
in person get to squeeze and probably
throw travis away for a little bit
do you guys think i'm small what if i
was like six foot five
i had a friend who was six foot five i
still tackled him to the ground so it's
fine yes exactly
if i was just like a lanky just like uh
that was literally my friend for years
that's
the reason i tackled him to the ground
is to save his butt from driving drunk
so i was like that's the only time i've
ever done that but
that's the stretch of the front is this
another flex right before we have to go
oh i saved my best friend's life
just if it wasn't for tommy it wasn't
with all of it
absolutely absolutely yes i'm looking
forward to it man i cannot wait gcx is
is coming through and i'm seeing a lot
of people throw the gtx over the
timeline so if you see us you see me
please say hello i love all that stuff
take a picture all that great stuff it's
fun and ee what's going on with you man
uh yeah gonna go visit my bro this
weekend hang out with my nephew shout
out to all of you guys with if you
listen to this one i don't know but i
know my brother probably will i don't
know if the nephews listen i'm not sure
they're uh age qualified for some of
this stuff
um but we'll see them and then i'm
honestly excited to
see my hosts like both of you guys
excited to hang out and i'm getting my
good vibes in now because it's just
going to be a weekend of you eat this
that and the other this way eating
habits is just going to get right
absolutely on fire and my wife is gonna
join in making fun of me so it's just
gonna be an entire weekend of crap
coming my direction
so i'm just you know trying to get get
what i can in now uh but other than that
uh this weekend as i said i'll be out uh
the
not too much in the way of content i'm
gonna try and see if i can you know
record a zerv video for my nephew's
computer we'll see if that actually
works that'll be an experiment uh but
other than that um yeah
hashtag uh
shill use cody bontis or iron lord at
checkout with advanced gg pick up the
new flavors you got focus
you've got shakers you've got and now
hydration which is caffeine free so if
you're not in that caffeine life but you
want something to taste good
they're actually really good
personally lemonade number one blueberry
pomegranate but again peach mango is
some people's favorite so if you want to
mix it up with something that's not
caffeinated they actually finally have
those now
um had to do it i had to live up to the
show man i just it
least i'm not out here hashtag pushing
powder like [ __ ] so listen out
i got to go to i actually respect his
transparency
i got i got it i gotta cater to my
demographic
it's they're responding hey it works you
use that sales pitch however it works
but no castle we have taken up enough
time you just casually implied that your
demographic is the type of people who do
powder that's just like yeah
you've been amazing um thank you all
very much chat you guys have been on
fire thank you for the super chats the
love and the support we will see you
guys very soon i can see the trail of
people falling off right now so good
night everybody and for this episode it
has been
the last word